we should be conspiracy theorists we
should assume that the politicians are
up to no good Dave column is back you're
in review you remember when the laptop
story broke how long did it take you to
figure out it was real uh as soon as
Twitter started blocking all the links
in the Ukraine story this year I happen
to run across a picture of a Ukrainian
nationalist with Q Anon Shaman at
January 6th what's that all about it's
not black and white there's a lot going
on here that isn't being covered and
maybe we should be asking a lot why do
we have 46 bio weapons left in Ukraine
science the last thing I want to talk
about is uh FTX quickly I picked up the
connection of FTX to Ukraine and to make
a long story short it looks to me like
FTX was never intended to be anything
but all right guys bang bang I am here
Dave column is back you're in review I
thought a great place for us to start
would be on the finance side uh over the
last three years we have seen absolute
insanity across financial markets
activity from the Federal Reserve we've
seen bull markets we've seen bear
markets asset price go up asset price go
down how do you start to just unpack
what's happened in finance and the
economy since the beginning of 2020 all
the way to the end of 2022.
well I go back to 1981
from a different Baseline but um
um
so the fed the FED in my opinion
um let the markets leave orbit
um in 1994-ish they that's when the
markets kind of took off and never
looked back and and and uh and you can
see it based on any valuation metric
that they they barely touched fair value
for the rest of the time and um and so
there was this accumulation of fuel in
the system that had not been burned off
and and Corrections corrected nothing
and I talked about corrections being um
a combination of price and attitude
correction and attitudes never got
changed so we we have 40 Years of
recency bias where you simply never get
punished for being in the markets that's
the rule You're simply never published
for be punished for being in the markets
um you get to uh 2020 so 2019 you get
that repo Madness period where actually
we're just talking about Grant Williams
before you before we went on
um one night Saturday night grant called
me for two hours we just talked about
the repo passes trying to figure out
what it was it's where the the repo rate
was spiking up to 10 right and uh and
and there was the at the end of the two
hours we concluded we had no idea what
was going on and it was fun to chat but
um
um and so then the FED sort of swooped
in to deal with that and I'm not sure
they knew what was going on I think it
might have been um the behavior of an
emerging system where where it just
started spazzing it just they didn't
know what was happening so they just
they just through all sorts of kerosene
on the thing or whatever you fan
whatever some some metaphor
um and then so what happens is they were
they were following um guidelines from a
white paper from BlackRock that had been
written in earlier in 2019 oh what a
coincidence right and black rocks
basically said in this white paper
um
the next Crisis you're not going to be
able to handle
and and and what you're going to have to
do is you're gonna have to shove money
directly into the consumer not just into
the system and it was called go direct
guy named John Titus had been talking
about this and um and so when repo
Madness came you can actually see the
the the the retail money supply they
have ways of dissecting them I don't
know how to explain this it's way above
my pay grade but you can kind of see the
money go direct uh not just into the
system in total meaning it didn't just
head off to the Federal Reserve as a
reserve it it didn't go into some
dormant sleepy place and um and then you
know within a couple of months coven
shows up now I blame the FED for the
coven lockdown and you say well how do
you do that I said well if the FED
hadn't said we will provide everything
you need to shut the whole goddamn
global economy down
then then we'll do it now if the FED had
said no we can't because we'll have an
inflation problem then there would have
been a lockdown it's that simple
and uh if they said we're not going to
backstop you you're on your own
um then then fouching these guys would
have been able to lock the economy down
and um
and so then that triggered you know
there's been inflation all along that
they've been lying about
this year I'm gonna have trouble because
I just wrote 200 pages on this [ __ ] and
so I'm going to keep referring back to
it I apologize but I wrote one of my
favorite inflation stories about a
blender that that broke that was 50
years old and then you replaced with a
new one it's a piece of [ __ ] and why
inflation doesn't pick up this changing
quality at all this bad downside change
in quality hedonics to this downside and
um and then I had just finished writing
it in my [ __ ] blender broke
this is an unbelievable timing my
blender broke and um and so uh so in any
case uh they triggered serious
undeniable into the DNA level inflation
and and when inflation gets in the DNA
it's it's no longer just to dial it up
dial it down inflation it's not like the
FED can say okay we'll just cut back a
little on the money supply or we'll cut
back a little on the flow it is now the
deeply embedded in the consumer psyche
and employer psyche so now they can't
get people to work for for lower wages
and they can't then things cost a
fortune my I published a tweet which my
brother keeps track of food he's he's
very well off but he keeps track of
everything he's an accountant and his
his food bill is up 41 year over year
and so when you have inflation of that
kind Jimmy iorio said in response to
that he said yeah his restaurant the
food Bill's up 24 25 year over year
and so the inflation had gotten real and
gotten serious and so now so now the FED
had that
and it's not clear that the FED really
has the tools to solve this inflation
problem because it's a very strange one
it's it's different as always but it's
got this before we get into the
inflation kind of uh getting under
control explain a little bit more your
comment about uh the FED playing a hand
in the government mandated lockdowns
because basically what you're arguing is
If the Fed was not willing to intervene
in the market and provide the amount of
liquidity if politicians also weren't
willing to provide the fiscal support
and basically bail out uh the consumer
and also certain industries then the
science organism if you will or the
science argument may not have led to the
government mandated lockdowns instead
there would have been more balance in
that debate
yes well first of all let me tell you
that the science behind the lockdowns
was Zero the the people making the
decision about the lockdowns were guys
who are not scientists
um Tony fauci's a [ __ ] on a scientific
scale he doesn't know anything and and
that comes straight from Scott Atlas who
spent months in the room with him and he
said he didn't have a shred of
scientific thinking in his logic and I
was on a zoom call with Scott and I was
pounding him with these little yes no
questions for about 20 30 minutes and uh
and he said fauci never once used a
scientific argument when he asked Burks
about the lockdown and about masking in
particular he said what's the best
evidence that masking does any good and
I'll I'll foreshadow the statement with
there's not there's profoundly good
scientific evidence that mass do nothing
there were 30 or 40 math studies prior
to covet during Flu epidemics and stuff
and not a single one found a
statistically significant Improvement in
in the pandemic or the epidemic or
whatever
from masking up the masks don't work and
and The Masks themselves don't work and
it even if they do at some level it's
like throwing stones in a in a Brook at
the end of the day the same amount of
water is going to end up down Downstream
even if you perturb the flow it's it's
still going to end up Downstream and so
uh so the masking was farcical and and
it was known to be far I read a book in
2005 called the great influenza and the
guy in that book said that they'd
studied masking and it was it it did
nothing it does absolutely nothing on
top of that the masses were being used
the bandanas and the rags and the you
name it the cloth mask they are
farcially bad that's like putting a
screen door in a submarine uh it just it
made no sense so so the masking was all
a ruse the question is why so when Berks
was asked the question why
um what's the best study so this is
atlas asking her what's the best study
to give you
um that you're using to justify masking
and she said the beauty salon study
now the beauty salon study was a beauty
salon where two girls masked in the
beauty salon and two did and the two who
didn't got sick
that seems like that's the beauty salon
study so so Berks is a [ __ ] she's a
twit fauci is not stupid but he's been a
bureaucrat for 35 years running all
sorts of bioweapons lab stuff and and
and he is not in any way a scientist
he's a uh he's a crook he's a mass
murderer he's all sorts of things but
he's not a scientist so the whole thing
was based on no science the entire
response was based on no science now now
what happens is the Fed provides the
financial backdrop
the the the monetary backdrop to allow
fauci and Burks to pull us off anyways
and when they do that is this going into
a room and they're like hey if we do the
mandates we need you guys to step in
okay yes we're going to step in okay go
issue the mandate to lock it down I
don't know how they covered it I don't
know how they did it now most of it was
most of the discussion was done in
meetings with Trump fauci Burks Atlas
and a bunch of others and uh and and
Foxy and Berks were running the
operation and Trump's biggest mistake
Trump's aren't a new thought she was
leading him off a cliff but he had
delegated and he stuck with his
delegation
and you think that was Trump's big
mistake that's Trump's big mistake
now is this something uh Twitter we now
are coming to find out the story that at
least is is being presented today is
that uh Jack Dorsey was the CEO he had
delegated a lot there was other people
who were doing all this kind of stuff
when Jack found out he did his best to
kind of correct the the course of the
ship uh was relatively unsuccessful in
doing that and he ends up leaving is
that a similar type example of what you
think was happening with the White House
during all of this where Trump had
delegated they started to go off course
and at some point did he try to step
back in and get him back on course or do
you think he was just along for the ride
uh Trump was to pre you know Trump's
Trump's idiosyncratic personality traits
were not helpful for this thing I mean
there's things that he's good at and
things he's not good at in a deeply
scientific based argument was not going
to be it and so Trump really sort of
delegated and said it's up to you guys
and he he should have stepped in
and he didn't I don't know why
um
um I I tried to pin Alice down a number
of times on on what they were up to and
Alice was very careful not to talk about
motivation whether it's a philosophical
point I don't know I even had the
passing thought that if he's positioning
for a for for a cabinet level position
some future Administration he's got to
watch what he says
um and so
um uh but but he he uh
he really just he's Burks would come in
and give pie charts and bar charts and
stuff in meetings
that she was dragging off the internet
same internet you and I use
and he said she had no idea what it
meant she had no idea about the
scientific basis of it she had no idea
even the quality of the source of it
and these were the two clowns and so he
says he's and when I said
I asked him if it was
what their intention was and he says
you've got to understand you you cannot
imagine the level of incompetence
in that room
he said it was just so profound and and
and and at one point
um
I said is it possible
that it wasn't out of
malevolence and that they
they really did what they thought was
right and he said well
given how stupid they are anything's
possible
and when asked someone asks about
reading Burke's book he said I didn't
read it I don't read fiction
and uh and she wrote a tell-all book
that made her look like a complete
[ __ ] she thought if she really got
honest that someone would say oh great a
refreshingly honest take and then fessed
up to [ __ ] everything up I mean it
was just it was just I I didn't read the
book I read excerpts of other people who
read the book but it was just a disaster
then she got a facelift I'm positive she
got a facelift so I said well at least
you look better now with your eyes
pinned back in your head you know I
don't know so so those two clowns got us
into a lot of trouble once we get into
that situation where the government
dated lockdowns uh the fed and Paul by
the way the Dorsey part I'm not sure
about the Dorsey part okay I've always
said that I think Jack is an honorable
guy
but Jack was also on one of the top he
himself was on one of the top commands
that handled the biggest decisions about
censoring
and I I I as far as I know he didn't
stop it now I it could have been he
could not control it
um I'm a little behind on the Twitter
files because I've been physically
writing and trying to get my life back
and stuff like that but um but it's it's
now pretty clear that the FBI invaded
social media and Google and and various
online things in a way that's Prof I
think profoundly unconstitutional I
think it's just so uh the other day
Jonathan Turley wrote an op-ed this said
it's time to have another church
investigation the FBI is completely off
the rails and and he just went through a
Litany of of things that the FBI's done
wrong that are you know 1950s bizarre
so the FBI is is looking very very bad
here do you know they paid a number of
these companies a number of media
companies millions of dollars to tell
the story about things like the laptop
that that's what's coming out of the
Twitter files yeah
Vivek ramashwami is yeah he uh recently
gave a speech and he basically said
listen uh First Amendment and private
companies and kind of that entire debate
with the social media companies make
sense uh and there's a debate worth
having but the second that the
government starts to uh go through the
back door and kind of allow the
companies or or pressure the companies
into doing their bidding for what they
couldn't do through the front door
because of the First Amendment then all
of a sudden that now brings the First
Amendment debate to these businesses and
so whether it is the government itself
not allowing Free Speech or if the
government is basically pressuring
organizations to not allow free speech
is there a difference I thought it was
just a fascinating uh thing because what
you start to get into is like how do the
courts look at that how are the courts
going to handle companies that are
essentially acting as an extended hand
for certain organizations or does the
court Say No actually that's not what
they're doing and they can tell the
organizations to kick rocks and they
don't have to follow you know their
instruction it's a very complex well so
well except
there's a kind of a foul libertarianism
a view that that says they're private
companies they can do what they want uh
to which I say okay so can I exclude
blacks from my Diner
and Society Long Ago said no
and so so so that's not clear
um I can't remember the number 20 30 or
something 230
um that basically says you're either a
platform or you're a media Outlet
and in one case you are responsible for
your content
and you can be sued if your content's
wrong and then the other you can't be
responsible but you also can't exclude
people if you're going to open the doors
to everyone you can't say oh but not you
black guys right so so I think that ship
is long since failed and I think that
the the the the social media companies
live long since overstayed overplayed
the hand that well we're private
companies we can exclude anyone we want
and uh and I think
whether they like it or not Twitter's
the Public Square it's where people
speak
um and and if they really want to accept
liability for what we say I'm I'll power
to them because I want to see them get
sued into Oblivion
if that's the case and they don't want
that so either you let us all talk
and and I'm willing to give them a
little attitude about you know you know
sort of inciting violence and yelling
fire in a theater and that sort of thing
they get a little attitude to to edit
but but you know less is more I'd rather
be in a in the wild west to free speech
than have
some douchebag with a ponytail in
Silicon Valley editing my stuff
how do you think this changes with Elon
gaining ownership of the business
fascinating question the question is is
Elon
is Elon really believe everything he's
doing
and and he's certainly playing it well
right he really looks like the the White
Knight but if you you read something
like the great reset one of the theories
on the great reset is all these
douchebags like class Schwab or mental
up evil and then some white and Idol
shop and clear them all out and we'll go
Hallelujah and it'll be [ __ ] Adolf
Hitler right and so the question is
um is Elon really sincere is this coming
from the heart or is this Elon is one of
the great minds in the great grifters of
the modern era he's both
and so the which are we seeing and we're
either seeing a phenomenal grift or a
phenomenal sort of intellectus had
enough I don't know now you got to
remind yourself that every single
industry's ever been involved in is deep
state connected
every single one
so he's he's got he's he's deep state
from head to toe
so the question then is is a guy who's
who's that sort of tied to the you know
whether it's Rockets or or Battery
Technology or whatever
um is that guy all of a sudden gonna
defy the Deep State I it could be a
farce
could could be a ruse I don't know I'm
hoping he's doing it I mean I'm really
praying he's doing it because we
desperately need him to do it
we need more people to do it we need him
to be a role model
explain a little bit more the idea that
Elon Musk is both a great mind and a
great grift
well he's a phenomenal hoser right I
mean he's phenomenal like marketing he's
got that he's kind of got a Steve Jobs
like marketing eye and and he's
certainly anyone who can build companies
to shoot Rockets to the moon and drive
build new brand new electric cars and
stuff and pay it was it PayPal where he
started I think this is this is the guy
whose mind is unconstrained compared to
most people's there's very few people in
the world who can think that big and put
it into action and and and
um and and uh
he's not he's not he's not stuck in it
but in a dotted line at all and so I
think he is a genius and I I think he's
funnier now I mean there's no question
and I like to associate humor with
genius
um and so I I think he's a great mind
and he's also a hoser he he's been able
to fund Tesla Through The Years by all
sorts of cool stuff like you know
trading Bitcoin right trading Dogecoin
and things like that he recognized the
wild west of the various cryptos
and realized that he could put money in
and pump it and sell it and then the
laws were being broken right and so he
he was able to he's been able to cook
his books pretty good do you think
that's what he's saying do you think
he's been doing that do you think he's
been well I think he's cooking him in
the in the maybe not in the illegal
sense but but if you're a car company
and you're finding yourself by pump and
dumps on crypto
it's odd I don't know if it's illegal
but it's it's odd you know it's it's
like a micro sailor right sailor just
flat out openly just trades crypto right
but but Elon did it to sort of raise
money
when you see uh kind of the asset bubble
that was created from 2020 into 2021 and
as you said might have even started in
the 80s and 90s with some corrections
along the way
what is kind of your view now in
hindsight with a little bit more clarity
an understanding that obviously prices
have come down we have some tech stocks
down 90 95 percent Bitcoins down 75
percent we've seen the indexes come down
20 30 percent uh how do you look at that
asset bubble and what do you think it'll
be written as in the history books will
it be the greatest asset bubble of all
time
yes
um yes because it's been the longest
duration
so most asset bubbles are real you know
sharp rise and fall right so they they
look like the Washington Monument
um this thing this thing has built over
years
um I really do think the markets left
fair value if you look I look at 25
metrics evaluation and you can say well
this metric shows this I go look I've
got 25 that all kind of line up
and and they they all show
that around 1994 the markets just took
off and and evaluation metric is is the
price of the market relative to
something that the market
ought to track
and so you know Everyone likes buffets
because it's price to GDP
you go wow the GDP screwed up because
well screwed up because for two things
one is it's inflation corrected but the
inflation number sucks so you can make
the argument that it's over the the
Market's even more overvalued using that
but then others point out well the GDP
of our of U.S companies the S P 500 are
now much more Global and so price of GDP
is not a good metric anymore and I go
but that's your regressible situation
too that's a regressible that can be
regressed to the mean if we de-globalize
that's all going away
and so uh so that could be just a trend
line that's not a forever trend line but
on top of all that
um I've got 24 more
that they all generally agree so at the
end of 2021 I did every several years I
do this I did a full analysis of Market
valuation I look went through the 25
metrics and looked at where they broke
away from fair value every one of them
busts away at night in 1994-ish that
turns out to be two things one is
um one is that's when we had to bail out
the bond market
and and the second thing that Mike Green
came in on and I can't disagree with him
um I was on a Twitter spaces or
something green jumped in and and I
think he thought I had it wrong I said
but I think he was actually saying in
addition he might not have been saying
it but I infer in addition that's when
uh index investing really kicked in
and so uh and so propelled by Mindless
money
and and a generous fed and the FED just
decided they just liked what they were
doing they just got a kick out of them
they had a they had a they started
they started in 1981 with interest rates
so high they had so much runway to work
with to bring down interest rates
methodically it's almost linear right if
you look at interest rates it's almost
like they said okay we can get 30 or 40
years of wrapping rates if we do this
right it's almost like someone saw that
and and so
so they just kept tapping the rates on
and tapping them down and when you tap
the rates down you tap the equity prices
up because every nitwit thinks if you
have a bubble if you compare your uh
Equity index to something else that's
also getting overvalued that that's a
good idea so if you want to say you know
the the FED model which says that stocks
are fair valued because interest rates
are low
well that's fine but it's it's like
saying that you know buying a Toyota
Camry for a hundred thousand dollars is
fine because because the Honda Accord
also costs a hundred thousand it's just
it's a bad metric and and interest rates
won't stay low forever it feels like
forever right 40 Years of dropping rates
feels like forever
but it's not forever and now they're
going up and and the equity Market is
now ignoring that so interest rates have
done what the 10 years almost it's
doubled at least right more
and equities didn't cut in half you know
a few select companies did but they've
just the equity Market has taken off the
froth
it goes back less than two years do you
really think two years of growing froth
is all there is to this bear market and
I think not I think I think that's a
farsically minor amount of Correction
I think we're going to go by the way my
friend at that Founders dinner who shall
remain nameless in the public podcast
said
um said he thought the last two book
bull markets are going to be given back
and when I tried to pin him down he
wouldn't he wouldn't say what his
definition of a bull market was
my definition is night 2009 to 2022 is
one
and two thousand uh 2003 to 2009 seven
is another I'll give them that you give
back those two now we're back into
triple digit s p
you think that's going to happen
uh no I I don't think in in in nominal
dollars it'll happen I think the s p
should be
should be sitting in the team somewhere
right now
there's a lot of people who that would
scare the [ __ ] out of them I hope so
indeed it should and why do you think
that even though the FED has been
aggressively hiking interest rates and
creating tighter Financial conditions
over the last 12 months and we have seen
you know 20 30 Corrections in the
indexes and some of the other assets
coming down what's the s p right now
it's like down what 12 or something
something yeah and so nothing so do you
think that the fed and those tighter
Financial conditions just don't have the
same impact or what gets us a deeper
drawdown than what we've already seen
us recency bias it's you there's a
stickiness to the system so so if if you
convince people that every dip should be
bought
then for a long time every dip will be
bought
and then over time these stip buyers
will start getting getting uh getting
hurt
they'll start going you know I I bought
the dip and for a while I was doing okay
and and but you know the lower highs
lower lows model is how they grind you
to dust if you and my favorite one you
know there's bear markets that you can
look at as models the Nikkei topped in
89.
and it took uh I don't know 15 18 years
to plumb the bottom
Vanessa's non-inflation corrected it
took that long
and so the anyone who tried to invest in
the Nikkei from 89 on forget about if
you you had your money in it already
let's say you were a young punk you got
a job in in Tokyo at 22 years old it was
1989. you couldn't make any money
period
when George George Noble one day said to
me oh yeah you can short it I go no you
couldn't you know that's true you can't
short a market that takes 18 years to go
down
do you feel like that is what is
possible here do you think we could be
in I think it's probable you think that
it is probable that the U.S indexes
could be in a bear market for a very
long time whether that's you know five
plus years or 18 years generational
generational yeah I think we're looking
at a generational bear Market unpack
this a little bit more because I think
this is uh okay something that people
are not hearing from many people okay so
I made a chart using Ron Greece's chart
and chem draw to add the arrows if you
look at what happens now we might have
talked about this before but people have
short memories so it's not a problem if
you if you look at what happens from the
top
oh six top 1929 top uh 1967 top whatever
you you look at what happens from that
point on what everyone focuses on first
of all if you're not an inflation
correct you're just an idiot you got
inflation correct you can include
uh dividends but if you're going to
include dividends you also have to
include fees and taxes it's amazing how
close those come to zeroing out
because dividends in the Haiti of
dividends were four percent well during
the Heyday of dividends fees were about
two percent I mean they were not cheap
and and taxes were so you made a few per
a percent or two maybe off the
non-capital game
so if you inflation correct the s p from
the turn of the century
and you draw a straight line from the
1906 top
and you ask the question how long does
it take to recover it's like 20 years
right so that's generational but here's
the thing people don't know is that if
you ask the question when did it not
only get back to that value but when did
it reach that value
for the last time not the first time
and so usually you finally break through
the 20 year old value and then you and
by the way Europe is that right now
Europe has been treading water for 20
years Germany big big economy it's been
treading water for 20 years
so anyway so you go from 1906 about 20
years later I think it recovers
and uh and then uh
and then uh and then it goes up for a
while and then it comes back down and
it's amazing it comes right it came
right back down to that same value
as 1906.
75 years later
from 1929 it went from the 1929 top
in a returned inflation adjusted to the
same value in 1981.
if you are at a top
you can't win from there there's no way
to win unless you're unbelievably
dexterous there might be good value but
hospitals say look you know you got a
stock that's got a PE of 10 you're going
to make you know 10 in theory if it's if
it's Gap if it's really good Gap and
these guys really do or crank the
printing presses and they're making you
money
but the price of those shares can cut
the PE to five
when the pe7 half the stocks are below
seven
so if we regress to a single digit p e
right if you look at if you look at the
gains off 1981 inflation adjusted it's
about six percent half of those are PE
expansion
half of those are PE expansion
as you look going forward
and we go through a generational bear
market so let's say that your probable
uh outcome occurs
how do you invest in that what did you
do you just said you know you just sit
out
it's it's my analogy is it's stage four
cancer and you say to your doc what do I
do and he says get your Affairs in order
so you you the problem is if if you're
not in good shape at the end of the
greatest run in the history of Finance
if you're not in great shape like so
many Pension funds are not in great
shape
you're never going to do it right if you
can't take 81 to 20 1981 to 2022 and get
yourself in good shape you owned it you
really screwed the pooch you want to
know what uh event
was like the big red flag to me there's
a lot of like smaller red flags along
the way even if you go back to before uh
the pandemic when we had the inverted
yield curves and CEOs leaving at
all-time high rates and all that type of
stuff
but the one that I remember uh I can't
remember if I sent an email or I said it
to uh to a friend of mine I said hey did
you see Calpers is taking on Leverage
yes oh my God I said everyone but
everyone's shaking on Liberty Calpers
taking on Leverage What a disaster well
they had Kentucky Kentucky has funded 22
percent in their State Pension Plan
Indiana Illinois these these states are
insolvent and you say well then there's
going to be a big bailout and you go yes
but now we have inflation
and so those big bailouts put a brick
wall right in front of the the the the
inflation but the brick wall in front of
the bailout so so now the FED has to
face some reality now the FED has got to
either be uh support
um support uh asset markets and currency
destruction
or they have to support
um the currency and the Integrity of the
Fed
which are they going to choose
so I want to unpack this specific point
around uh you said earlier that
inflation is now in the DNA we I think
the November 2021 so from November 2020
until November 2021 uh the inflation
rate was like 6.8 percent for the
trailing CPI yeah
before that it was like 1.2 1.4 so if
you go from 2019 to 2020 you get like
less than one and a half percent you go
from 2020 to 2021 you get 6.8 percent
and now we have just over seven percent
from 21 to 2022. we are compounding the
compound annual growth rate of inflation
is now over six and a half percent and
what we are starting to see is that it's
showing up obviously in prices we know
wages aren't keeping uh pace and so I
don't think anyone is confused or at
least anyone who with half a brain does
not believe that prices are going to
come back down you're not going to see
McDonald's and Chipotle drop their
prices their grocery stores not going to
go and put a 20 30 percent uh drawdown
in prices across the store or anything
like that yeah inflation is infinitely
sticky yes so now that we are here
normally unless we have a catastrophe
okay if we get a real deflation then
that bad deflations are are feared by
Central bankers and there's a variety of
reasons one of which is if you have a
deflation and everything then um first
and foremost you can point straight at
the central bank and say it's your fault
you did it so so Central Bankers do not
want that hanging around their neck
second of all let's say asset prices go
down for uh for 20 years I
where the capital gains tax is going to
come from
it's not a taxable gain
it's a taxable it's a tax break so it
all it just screws up that pattern too
and so so Central Bankers hate hate
deflation deflation is an incredibly
rational thing in a real world of of a
non not so flexible money supply which
is what you holders are trying to
achieve
um
when when you put out a loan and you
charge and you charge someone uh uh uh
uh you charge them five percent interest
you got to ask the question where does
that five percent come from
right so I got an argument with David
and the Father the vice president of St
Louis fed he's kind of on the Spectrum
but he to his credit he would engage
with the masses including me and um he
said that volcker volcker fought
inflation early but his policies became
inflationary
like oh [ __ ] I've never heard that what
what he what are you talking about and
he said he made the case and I'm not
sure I didn't fill in the gaps or he
made it explicitly but basically if
you're seven fifteen percent into
everyone's money market account
the year shoving 15 more money into the
system more spending power into the
system and that is inflationary
so while rates are high
you have this massive influx of money
now here's a plot that I only know of
one person who's created it
and and it seems so obvious to do
although now they don't report M2
anymore but if you want to correct for
inflation
instead of using CPI which they've
completely screwed up from head to toe
right completely the Boston commission
turned it into a fourth trimester
abortion
um the
you would plot the asset markets
corrected for M2 money supply that would
be a pretty rational way and a pretty
numerical way to correct for inflation
and I'm too I you know I'm not an
economist but if you know it's the cash
in the bank and so some pretty low level
money supply thinking it's not
derivatives it's not all that weird
stuff but if you correct for M2 money
supply
from 1920 to the present
the s p hasn't moved
is it possible I ask is it possible that
the capital gains in the S P 500 for a
hundred years
have been zero correcting for that
metric of inflation
so I've talked about this too much
people actually have gotten mad that if
you go back to 1971 and when we went off
the gold standard gold standard and you
basically denominate the indexes in gold
or other types of uh assets rather than
the US dollar many of them are flat or
down some of them actually have lost
money right and so when you you go
further back you know called 100 years
or so uh it is interesting because you
could basically look at there was a gain
on the first 30 years and then you
basically took a loss in the last 70 and
you basically end up flat you know give
or take and kind of round numbers if you
will and so if you're flat for 100 years
and actually the the change in value is
the debasement of the currency
then it starts to bring up a lot more
analysis in terms of wages how have
those changed you start to look at is
the consumer is the investor is the
business better off today than they were
20 50 100 years ago
and I think there's a very strong case
that that may not be true well so here
here's here's an interesting case that
I'll make for you though there's a
question that gets asked and apparently
when it when the poll goes out you get
about the same percentage answer every
time and that is would you rather live
in 1925
on a fifty thousand dollar salary
or in 2022 on a fifty thousand dollar
salary
now think about it there's there's
layers to that onion you obviously are a
rich man in 1925.
but think of all the things you don't
have
and the one that causes 86 percent of
the people to choose the modern fifty
thousand dollars is Healthcare
I think that they realize like oh holy
[ __ ] I could die of an ear infection
I think otherwise it might be a great
time to live but don't forget she got no
TV you got no other things you really
like doing and so being rich you know
you get to you know troll around get
chicks hot chicks you know but your
wife's hot so you don't need any more of
that
um and uh and such an interesting
question so so there is something that
the hedonic adjusters have right and
that is that there there has been an
improvement in quality of life
in some way in in various intangible
ways well I think the uh well yes there
are absolutely objective improvements in
life from a technology standpoint
Healthcare we can go down the line
there's a bunch of stuff right and I
think right uh the Techno Optimist
believe that is going to continue
forever if you read uh the rise in uh
fall of American growth which I think
you've recommended multiple times to
folks uh there's kind of this you know
50-ish uh period of time maybe 70 years
whatever it was where there was an
explosion of connectivity and is that a
great book amazing
book it's probably one of my favorite
books that I write I got another one for
you now you know it because I emphasized
it the True Believer the True Believer
the True Believer my introductory
section I emphasize the True Believer if
you read one book this year Erica for
1953 The True Believer he will explain
the world to you in a little tiny half
the Normal book size book it's just an
amazing book it's so got into my DNA it
explains mass movements and and why they
form and why what gives them oxygen and
I spent a lot of I spent a lot of time
writing about it and I hated doing it
because if you go to read it just say
well column already told me the plot but
it was so important to me that I
couldn't say go to Amazon trust me
and so I I so in my my pin tweet if you
guys are tweeters out there which most
of you are my guess go to my uh um go to
my pin tweet and read the introduction
to my to my year in review and it
emphasizes it's got an Eric offer theme
and I think it's I think it's
some things I write are okay some things
I think are great that's that's one of
the great ones
when you look at the analysis that you
described in terms of going back fifty
thousand dollars in 1925 or whatever it
is or fifty thousand dollars today
there's a strong argument that actually
people are sicker today they're more out
of shape they are Dumber because they
say hey wait a minute watch your step
there buddy
and they sit in a doom scroll on social
media like all these things right it's
this fascinating question because you
can't just look at all of the positive
improvements because there's also been
some of that technology uh some of those
improvements have led to degradations in
the quality we're living longer we're
and so there is no uh I think easy
analysis but also uh it scares the [ __ ]
out of people to go backwards I think
there's like a psychological uh
um whether it's a bias or fear or
whatever it is where the idea of going
back when uh you don't have TV when you
don't have a smartphone in your pocket
when you don't have you know Healthcare
as you described you can't imagine how
people live that way my childhood was
great
so my child you know so odd my mother
was a profound alcoholic I mean really
sort of in your your face in the mashed
potatoes at dinner alcoholic right and
uh and I still had a great childhood
somehow my dad raised us to to deal with
her as though you would deal with having
a [ __ ] sibling or something right
and and we just we would go out in the
woods and we'd build forts and we'd go
we we'd steal you know from local
building contractors their their cement
tub and we drag it to the lake and use
it as a boat and we just we just just
had a great time and and and we didn't
have all the [ __ ] and we had three
TV channels up in the Adirondacks I have
a cabin as you recall because that's
when the dogs were giving me [ __ ] on our
last podcast
he is a legend he
um and so uh I read comments and people
say I would never read the comments I
read comments because there is content
in there and it's like watching the game
film and say oh my god oh I can't
believe I threw the ball into that guy's
hands right
um but um people were saying I should
stage it better and I go I'm in the
[ __ ] Adirondacks you idiots they
thought I was Ted Kaczynski or something
the other amazing thing well really
amazing about the last podcast which I
thought by the way went really well and
you may have noticed in this year review
I gave your podcast top billing I
appreciate that out of about 50.
um
um what I noticed is I made some joke
about inflation I said people don't have
400 to rub together and now you know
that to replace the microwave which is
about what a microwave costs now right
and you wouldn't believe the number of
commenters oh he lost me when he said a
microwave cost 400 I go really that's
what it takes to lose you what do you
got ADHD hey there's a squirrel go chase
it you [ __ ] you know it just it just you
know I'm Amazed by the what what comment
section shows how many sociopaths there
are in the world because I have to I all
you have to do is read the comments and
go you really just said that it's just
okay so a microwave oven doesn't cost
for a hundred dollars and maybe I was
being facetious maybe I was maybe I'm a
clueless idiot but my God they say I
stopped listening when he said a
microwave cost four hundred dollars
really you can't mess with the microwave
people the microwave
microwave the microwave industrial
complex
um all right I want to uh move on
because we got a whole bunch of stuff we
got to get through
um next thing that I want to talk about
uh you did talk about this last time but
it was more of a a passing thought and I
want to read you a specific three or
four sentences from uh from the letter
uh summarizing 2022 you said my training
as a parent tells me those demons are
scheming so indeed I am a conspiracy
theorist if you are not one ignorance is
bliss hang on to those lovely thoughts
and what you're talking about here is
people in positions of power and
influence and last time when we talked
you mentioned someone in an offhand
comment uh conspiring is what people do
when they come together and they
conspire to do something and so you're
now going from offhand comments to
explicitly calling out much more I think
your expectation and the way you analyze
these situations so I thought it'd be
fascinating when you read something in
the news
how far on the I believe versus I
started this is total [ __ ]
do you start like where on that scale
are you when you read something in the
news well it depends on the author for
starters okay because if I'm reading
Matt Tybee I assume or Glenn Greenwald I
assume they're trying to get it right
and I will read anyone who's trying to
get it right I've been denouncing the
use of conspiracy theorists as a
pejorative for many years now in fact
the one you just read was very mild I
know I used to it I used to attack those
if you call me a conspirac if you if if
I'm in a conversation anyone says well
you know I'm not a conspiracy theorist
but I will stop them dead in their
tracks right there on the spot and say
why did you just say that
and and I make them defend using that
phrase I said you're about to tell me
something about someone conspiring to do
something bad and yet you're saying
you're not a conspiracy theorist we
should be conspiracy theorists we should
assume that the politicians are up to no
good we should assume that the Press has
been bought and paid for at this point
because all evidence points to it once
the Press is bought and paid for they're
lying to you the last podcast I did was
as recently as yesterday and if you can
Wade through all the goddamn f-bombs
that I dropped there was content in
there somewhere but um but it was with
Chris irons right and and and I I was
out f-bombing Chris like there was no
tomorrow I think he's gone uh I think
he's gone Hollywood or something he was
very tame
um but but but if you're in the press
and you're lying to me you're my enemy
you're supposed to be trying to get to
the truth that's what the Press is
supposed to be the Constitution kind of
gave you special privileges
so that you would help us and if you I
don't care if you're lying in favor of
the right or against the right or in
favor of the left or against the left if
you're lying to me you are my enemy I
want Edward R Murrow back and he was
probably lying too but I didn't know it
you know we didn't I and so so uh so if
you're sitting there telling stories
like the laptop is fake and you know
you're lying
you're a liar right you're despicable
human being I I have nothing but bad
things to say about you now do you think
they thought they were mine
yeah I think they did
you you know you remember when the
laptop story broke how long did it take
you to figure out it was real
uh as soon as Twitter stop started
blocking all the links it didn't take
that long because you know okay so so
someone gets you a copy of the laptop
how do you check it well you go to the
email and you say oh gee whiz he sent an
email to this guy in the state let's ask
the guy if he got an email on that date
and if he did you've got the laptop
it's that simple so you knew the laptop
was real
and and the blocking was very fast when
they kicked the New York Post off
Twitter
right the oldest newspaper in America
that kicked off Twitter blocked that
story you knew the laptop was real there
was two moments where I knew stories
that maybe people uh weren't as excited
about were likely to have more uh weight
to them more accuracy than uh uh than
initially thought and both times it was
because someone got kicked off Twitter
when Zero Hedge dropped the
um uh Wuhan uh virology Institute
information
and they literally had like here's the
doctors and and uh uh I think they put a
phone number and email that was publicly
available on the website and that's what
you know the doxing rule uh was somehow
and then the foia releasing vouch's
emails were found she sends an email
that post to Zero Hedge Lincoln says we
gotta get on this yes
so uh that one I was like oh somebody
should just go do some more research and
then I actually I don't know if you
remember this
um very shortly after there uh there was
a call an open source document I came
here for the Google Doc or something got
put together there's a PDF
um and the writers of it were uh
Anonymous no one knew who put it
together but it was very well researched
it was obvious that these are
intelligent sophisticated people who
understood science and geopolitics and
all this stuff and they put together
this document and I still today believe
that they likely did it anonymously uh
as a response to having seen what
happened to Zero Hedge so that was one
and then two was when uh when the links
got blocked on the New York Post story
again not because I had some insight or
thought that uh it's 100 true but just
it is the classic like somebody tells
you don't look here and every human goes
well what's there why don't you I just
knew the New York Post wasn't going with
a fake laptop story I just do it's like
when the Snowden papers come out did you
question them
not a bit not a bit you knew you knew
that that's such a blockbuster that
anyone who went forward with that and if
they were wrong would be destroyed
and so
um and so so that the FBI has become
basically the praetorian guard
if the Republicans get in power they
will be the Republicans Victorian guard
maybe
um when Elon went to buy Twitter and the
left [ __ ] their pants
it was very very clear that that they
were about to lose a tremendous tool
that they were using against the right
now there is this sort of you know
one-party view of the world that says
this party is is they're they're all the
same party there's no difference and I
there's some truth in that
but the evils of the world I see right
now are coming from the left
and I've looked for them on the right
I've made that assertion to people and
said give me examples
um you know I look at I look at January
6 and and what I see in January 6 was an
optically bad moment I see uh I see the
FBI infiltrating
uh infiltrating the crowd causing
trouble
I happen to run across in the Ukraine
story this year I happen to run across a
picture of a Ukrainian nationalist which
we should get to before this thing's
over
with Q Anon Shaman at January 6th
I'm going what are those two doing
together January 6. what's that all
about explaining explain this more
because people who haven't read this yet
uh the the imagery is uh and again I am
uh deferring to you that uh obviously
the other person is uh who wherever you
found the image uh is who they are
saying it is there's no way for me it's
a picture so it's either photoshopped
correct but but but there's a lot of
pictures of this guy with Q Anon shot
there's a picture of the guy with q and
on Chapman
and then there's all sorts of pictures
showing he's a Ukrainian nationalist
which is a sanitized version of saying
he's a Ukrainian Nazi
now you will be told by mainstream media
this year the Ukrainian Nazis are a
conspiracy theory all you have to do is
go on Twitter here's my your homework
assignment go on Twitter and search
azoff Battalion a-z-o-v azov Battalion
and start reading tweets it's nothing
but awfulness it's just going back years
if you want set a time frame you know
civil rights groups and and and and and
World organizations watching out for the
well-being of humanity have been
denouncing the Aesop Battalion the whole
time what is that but that it's a
military it's a it's it's a military
group in Ukraine that are a bunch of
Nazis they trace their Roots back to
World War II where they were fighting
with Germany against Ukraine and against
the Soviets
and they were genocidal they were they
were anti-semitic they were everything
you'd expect out of a Nazi those guys
made it through to the present now
they've had highs and lows but in 2014
they really got their feet on the ground
after the uh the maidan
um
um the maidan uh uh uh protests and the
the CIA sponsored coup of of don't make
me pronounce his name
I can spell it I can't write it uh I
can't say it um so so we toppled the
Ukrainian government put in our guy and
I'll admit that the previous guy was
Putin's guy but it's not put his back
doorstep so I you know who should have
this guy there
um and so in any event so the Ukrainian
uh Nazis really started getting legs now
these guys celebrate steppen Bandera's
birthday Stephan Banderas was Global's
buddy during the war he was a die-hard
Nazi
and these Ukrainian Nazis celebrate this
birthday and I've I provide links to
video footage and they're scary as hell
the best analogy I have is they're not
big in numbers maybe but they're like a
Mexican drug cartel they what they lack
in numbers they make up in ruthlessness
so those are the guys who are trapped in
the azov Asos style steel mill remember
that where they were they were in there
and they were supposedly protecting
civilians [ __ ] they weren't they
were using civilians as Shields and and
and Putin flushed him out of there
and I think they probably died a Grizzly
death because Putin's moving to Ukraine
we're probably jumping the gun in here
please move into Ukraine was to clear
the you the azoff guys out of there that
was why he invaded Ukraine it was to
clear out the Nazi movement in Ukraine
which was picking up speed thanks to
Nato
arms and training do you feel like it's
all right I got a couple questions uh
first that is the stated reason or one
of the stated Reasons from Russia and
Putin uh one do you believe that that's
actually why they did it and two do you
think that the Russian people believe
him when he says that
I think they do I did a poll on Twitter
and I said which leader most cares about
their own country
the choices I gave were Biden Trudeau
Johnson and Putin 71 Putin they can't
even convince guys in the U.S
that Putin doesn't care about Russia
potent is popular in Russia you look at
the last 15 years of Russian history
it's been pretty tame actually
and when I get into do you want to go
into Ukraine now and go into it I'm into
it already part of it's because it's
it's the core of my write-up this year
it's the one where I said okay I'm
bringing my a game for this write-up
um
but but uh Christian Freeland let's go
to the truckers remember it was the most
peaceful protest in the history of
protests these guys were clean in the
streets they were playing hockey on the
ice they were doing everything you'd
want to see in a protest people were
taking donuts and and bagels that that
feed them and and they were protesting
that they didn't want to get vaccinated
and then Trudeau and Christia Freeland
stepped on them like Nazis now I'll say
like Nazis
so they stepped at him like
authoritarians and they shut off their
bank accounts they threatened to kill
their dogs they disabled their trucks
they shut down funding campaigns they
did everything that and the reason was
is because they could have just said
okay you guys don't have to vaccinate we
got the message we don't care that's
fine it was time to stop the vaccination
anyways but they couldn't give the
deplorables the victory
they could not in any way let truckers
win because they could win in every
country in the world so they had to
squash them like bugs now who's Christia
Freeland well Christia Freeland is
Ukrainian
she used to be a work in Ukraine
her grandfather was a Ukrainian Nazi
she is in the world economic forum
she has the resume of a bad person
she is on the short list to be the
Secretary of NATO
so when you see them step in with the
trucker specifically one of the pieces
that I think shocked people was not that
they uh pushed back stepped on the
protest all that like I think now people
understand like hey this idea of
protesting governments they're not cool
with it they may say they're cool with
it but for the most part unless they
agree with uh what you're protesting
about they're gonna do things to
um uh to deter this to stop this
whatever
but I think it was the way they did it
the cutting off of the bank accounts and
and just the treatment of citizens
in a way that you would treat quite
literally terrorists right people who
you thought had right uh some sort of uh
ill will
and I think if you walked around the
streets people would say no no we we are
in you know in this case Canadian and we
believe in Canada and we believe in the
freedoms of Canada and we believe in you
know XYZ uh uh components that make up
that country so it's very again kind of
shocking when they started to use tools
that previously had been reserved for uh
what most people I think would have said
uh were appropriate measures in stopping
terrorist financing or those types of
activities
I would say it was more appropriate for
someone in the Soviet Union to step on
that
I I to me it was just so off over the
top yeah
and just Justin Trudeau
made very Brash statements about the
being neo-nazis and about them being
being pedophiles and all he made all
sorts of accusations about the truckers
and he talked about taking away their
their personal freedoms he said it
I quote him and and and so Justin
Trudeau is a sack of crap
hey guys what's up hope you're enjoying
this episode with Dave column but
throughout the episode Dave said a
couple of things that YouTube they just
don't like they don't think we should be
allowed to speak our minds or say the
things that we think might be true so
rather than just edit them out we've
decided that we should let you know when
the video is being censored one of those
moments is right now there'll be a
couple more times throughout the episode
that you'll see me but we just want you
guys to know that we understand people
want to be able to hear the unfiltered
thoughts of our guests but we also have
to appease the YouTube Gods alright
let's get back to the episode with Dave
you guys will see me again in a few
minutes
foreign
so then you get so then you get um then
you get the uh the FTX collapse
before we get to FTX let's talk about uh
Russia and Ukraine because okay that's
where my heart is right now in February
my brother says I wiggle a lot that's
fine my brother says I wiggle you're
good sorry it's all good yeah okay in
February of 2021 we saw Putin go ahead
and uh and move into Ukraine uh invade
the country I think there's a lot of
people who thought it was all talk it
was all you know bark no bite he wasn't
gonna do it he did it
which I think includes the CIA and our
intelligence they thought it was all
bark and they'll bite okay
and once he did it it felt like there
was a pretty big shift there was a lot
of uh change in in the coverage in the
United States and globally there was uh
I think a lot of people in the United
States one of your comments in uh your
write-up was these geopolitical events
happen to teach geography to Americans
right people were like Hey where's
Ukraine and then they started to uh
unpack some of this and then frankly
there's a lot of people who just said
I don't know anybody in Ukraine I don't
know anything about this you know why is
the United States being involved and you
got kind of a very wide dispersion of uh
responses what's your read on the
situation why I would like to think
there was a lot of the latter but I
don't think there was
yeah I don't think
that was a popular response or one that
was the majority by any means
so here's the back story I went back and
looked at all the times I wrote about
Putin over the years it turns out my
first time I ever wrote about Putin was
in 14 which happened to be on the heels
of the the overthrow of the Ukrainian
government CIA sponsored
and it was I was just trying to
understand what was going on at a very
shallow level and I don't know anything
so I had this huge disadvantage of I I
literally was one of the guys who
couldn't pick Ukraine on a map
I mean I I you show me a picture of a
map I wouldn't have been able to assign
Ukraine so I actually put up a picture
of a map and I admitted that and I and I
admitted in my write-up that I started
from scratch and I had to First find
Ukraine on a map and I showed a map I
said was uh
was a Top Secret Pentagon map
and and and and some guy said oh he
doesn't have that he if he does he's uh
he must be a psyop blah blah blah it's a
[ __ ] risk board you morons I picked a
risk board
from the game Risk and and and and
what's funny is there's no Russia in the
game Risk they're all provinces I said
oh my God they've already taken Russia
off the map
um
so
so I had to start from scratch I didn't
know there's a civil war going on in
Ukraine for years
so the you the Western Ukrainian
with a core group of Nazis have been
slaughtering ethnic Russians in the East
for years slaughtering them
so this is not a simple story zielinski
it's a complete Hoser zalesky is
phenomenal at what he's doing
but he's every bit as dirty as slimy as
as any any other leader in that region
in the world where he where he he banned
the Catholic church he shut down his
opposing party shut down all the minor
parties he he he did he did all sorts of
bad [ __ ] and everything oh Nobel Peace
Prize I I'd take him to the Hague for
the [ __ ] he does but but so so when I
when I when I when I get into it with
people when I get really frustrated I
would drop to moral equivalency
and I would say okay okay before you you
wave your [ __ ] yellow and blue flag
one more time let me let me ask you this
question how many countries
over the last 20 years and how many
people have been killed how many
countries have been attacked and how
many people have been killed
by Russian by the United States
and it's not even close it's two decimal
points apart we have done
292 I think it's 292 military
interventions and since the mid 90s 292.
which of those countries attacked us
this year we we bombed Syria three days
in a row
and the official story was that it was
to send a message to Tehran
and I said in the write-up I said that's
odd I don't I didn't remember Tehran I
didn't remember that Tehran was in Syria
this is confusing to me
we bombed Syria to send Iran a message
what kind of War crime is that so I
quoted Madeline Albright admitting that
there were 500
000 children killed in Iraq 500 000
children and she said it was worth it
so please tell me how twisted she is
please tell me where was the video
footage of those bloated carcasses where
was the video footage of those dead
children
so so when you want to get all
teary-eyed and all oh you know give
zoleski the Nobel Peace Prize explain
where you were when the Saudis were
bombing Yemen and killing tens of
thousands with our weapons that we
provided
explain why so that why why why our more
recent liberal president which I don't
include
uh Biden uh
um
Obama I'm seven Muslim countries which
of those countries attacked us seven
Muslims which attacked us the hint none
attacked us
so who are the bad guys statistically
speaking we are the bad guys
flat out we are the bad guys I want to
be the good guys and I provided quotes
from the former Attorney General of the
United States Ramsey Clark saying that
the United States that quote was United
States it's not like the most War like
no Jimmy Carter said we're the most
warlike country in history
um that that that I think as Ramsey
Clark said that the the the greatest
crime has been U.S foreign policy
man you can go to guys like Chris Hedges
and find all sorts of hateful things and
and so so the bottom line is is that
that that while you're all sanctimonious
you the people
um about Ukraine you wave your flag and
you you show great hostility guys like
me who try to look at it through Putin's
eyes
just try reading something just anything
just read something so that you're not a
complete fool I call them the sanctimony
industrial complex they'll find a cause
to get all bent out of shape over but
when I get bent out of shape over
something I go read about it and I find
out what I'm bent out of shape over and
sometimes I'm wrong
so the bottom line is for years
back in the 2014 write-up I quoted John
meersheimer I had forgotten it John
meersheimer is a University of Chicago
policy wonk
who I've been in communication with
since I just rediscovered them
and he has been telling us that NATO has
been heading us for World War III for 10
years now he has been warning everyone
that will listen that NATO is taking us
to World War III in their actions
Ukraine is on Russia's borders
Putin has been saying you can't have
Ukraine you can't bring Ukraine into
NATO
it is an existential risk for Russia
it's not going to happen
and people say well you know who's here
to say that I go well we told [ __ ]
Cuba to take a hike we would tell yeah
how long would it take how long would it
take if Russia put missiles
in
Mexico for us to turn Mexico into a
sheet of glass
about five seconds
we would we would Scorch Mexico if there
were Russian Russian troops and or
weapons of any kind
so why is it that Putin doesn't have the
right to say look I for us Ukraine's it
so Putin brings in first the war started
out in this very odd way
um Putin had been warning you can't do
this you can't do this they had
Communications right up through 2021.
and the West we didn't just say look we
disagree because we say go [ __ ] yourself
we said we don't care you know why we
wanted Ukraine in a war with Russia
we wanted that so to us the ukrainians
are the same as the Irish infantry word
along to Long Shanks in Braveheart he
didn't care if they died we don't care
if the ukrainians died we're giving the
ukrainians weapons to go get slaughtered
and if you if you find the guys who are
telling the story so here are the names
you want to watch out for uh Colonel
Douglas McGregor he was uh in a position
to be a cabinet level military advisor
in the white house he was in a he was
going to be the ambassador to Germany
Senate uh vetoed it uh colonel colonel
um I think it's Stephen black he he was
in the Virginia Senate for for years he
was military using the the Marines for
31 years you got guys like more offbeat
guys like Oliver Stone you got um who's
actually very good
um you got guys like on Greenwald
there's there's dozens of people been
trying to tell the story
but the media doesn't want to hear it
the media doesn't want to hear it
because they're paid to tell the other
story
and so NATO is the cause of this war
data pushed Russia they had to move now
what was the proximate trigger that's a
fascinating thing was it the proximate
trigger that NATO was pushing Ukraine in
the NATO's pushing Ukraine to join NATO
they say well why is that so damn
important well what makes it so damn
important is that if if Ukraine's in
NATO
by treaty if Russia steps on Ukrainian
soil
everything kicks into gear everything
goes straight to now we gotta fight
Russia
and so so it's bad enough to be arming
the ukrainians with NATO quality crap
but to have Ukraine in NATO is like all
the the treaties that existed prior to
World War one they trigger events and
Putin said you can't do it and we should
have said okay we get it now when the
Berlin Wall fell the Soviet Union fell
apart Germany was being reunited
which had more than just the Russians
nervous because big Germany has done a
few bad things in its day
we promised written record we promised
the Russians that if they kept the
Warsaw Pact from being reassembled
we would not push East Eastward in NATO
that data would stay out of that zone if
Russia stayed out of that zone
and then we almost immediately put plans
into moving Eastward with NATO
and it started it finally started in 97
officially with Clinton and George
Cannon who's considered one of the
greatest cold Warriors of History
Shadow is the biggest U.S policy mistake
ever
when Clinton pushed NATO Eastward
and so we pushed NATO Eastward and we
flipped off Russia we said you don't
matter
and in a sovereign state does not want
to hear that
trying to disagree with them but they
don't want to hear that you don't matter
and then at one point Biden says that
word's her rhetoric get really bad this
is where it gets completely psychotic
first and foremost
um when Putin when Putin or Russian
speaks it's a single voice it's Putin's
voice to be frank right so when lavrov
says something it's Putin it's all been
cleared Putin Russia lavrov all these
Russian guys all speak from a single
Playbook
when NATO speaks it's a bunch of whack
jobs it could mean anything from as as
high up
as as as a high-ranking person in the
White House who's higher ranking than
Biden who's losing his marbles
but when Biden says the regime has to go
when when when
um when John Bolton writes an opera that
says we have to assassinate Putin we
have to set up an assassination of Putin
how are you going to explain to me
that's not existential risk so Biden
says regime has to go and some some
newspaper said oh that's the most
aggressive stance towards Russia since
Ronald Reagan
I don't know that's [ __ ] Reagan
never said the regime had to go you say
a regime has to go
you're saying go ahead light the place
up now
we yeah we're gonna take you out so so
it's Goblin time it's a Green Goblin
strategy you want a nuclear war
you tell Putin that's his only option
you'll get a nuclear war now we hear
about how Putin was pushing nuclear war
now he was
at all he wasn't our press was pushing
the idea that he was pushing nuclear war
and we had Senators saying we should arm
Poland with nuclear weapons we had
Senators saying we should attack
preemptively
because NATO speaks in a bunch of voices
of a bunch of loose cannons with our
weapons are loose cannons with
double-digit IQs
and so the NATO message is crazy you got
Kamala Harrison or Dr Seuss imitation
over in Poland
um
and so
um and so uh you know uh mirchimer sent
me a debate he did against Sikorski he
used to be the Secretary of Defense of
Russia of Poland
and mirchimer really didn't like the
debate he thought he thought he and
mcfaul who's a pathological liar to
Russia when you're when you're when
you're a diplomat
to a country you're you're really not
supposed to lie according to the sort of
the coin Amir shimer who studies this
stuff he says when when our leaders talk
to us they lie their ass off when they
sit down and they break bread and they
talk to each other they don't lie they
call a spade a spade
and mcfaul was so proud of the fact that
he was lying his ass off to the Russians
all the time
and so McFall is Sikorsky debated Steve
Walt and John meersheimer
and I was I found Sikorsky repugnant
so then months later there's Sikorsky
saying we've got to arm Poland with
nuclear weapons to go after Russia
how is this not existential risk for
Russia they want to put weapons within
seven minutes Striking Distance of
Moscow
how is that not a threat to Russia
so we've been we I'm positive NATO could
have stopped this war
at many many points along the way what
do you think they should have done
stop the war yeah but how how would they
uh if you were running NATO and now
obviously with hindsight uh benefit
where do you think those points are that
they could have stopped it
any point just literally says
Putin was saying I want in writing that
you guys are not going to move but
you're not going to take Ukraine into
NATO
he he's been saying it the whole way you
can't have Ukraine he wasn't saying he
had to have Ukraine
he was saying you can't have Ukraine he
was happy to have Ukraine just be there
he had serious tactical issues with
having the ability to deal with Ukraine
rationally
so he had pipeline issues and he has he
has the Soviet you know uh the naval
fleet stuff he had to have Ukraine
accessible to Russia The Invasion Force
wasn't an occupying force it wasn't big
enough
The Invasion Force went into Ukraine to
take out the Nazis which were the
problem do you think and again now we're
in the speculation land so it's
impossible to know the whole way what
could happen
um but do you think that if NATO had put
in writing we will not bring Ukraine
into NATO uh that would have been the
end of it or do you think that he still
would have gone in uh for this asmov uh
or as off uh battalion no that would
have been the end of it you think I I
think I I absolutely believe that okay
yeah so we'll never know okay so this
was going to be my question is so what
was the trigger this is this is back to
the trigger I don't think the trigger
was the NATO okay what was it so so why
after all these years did Putin finally
move
and what happened was I got two emails
from guys who I don't know it's one of
these things like I'm now friends with a
Canadian military Intel guy who sent me
an email and reached out tried to tell
me something absurd about the covet
virus
and he was in the the military games in
Wuhan in October
of 2019. and he said all the athletes
got sick and Wuhan was a ghost town
and those two put together says maybe
that's when the virus got released now I
didn't know who this guy was he was
trying to get my attention I was you
know I'm human turns out he's Canadian
military Intel he's got boots on the
ground and Ukraine given of information
and he's confounded at what the hell's
going on there so this is a complicated
story so
um I think Putin was asking for an
absolute openly stated willingness to
back away from Ukraine
and the U.S and NATO don't didn't want
to do that and still don't want to do
that because they viewed it as like
showing weakness or no black black again
these are just opinions but black thinks
it's just a research graph NATO which is
the U.S
watch the resources
of Ukraine and Russia
now I read an article that went way back
and I quoted it that said
NATO's biggest concern are the US's
biggest concern
is an alliance between Germany and
Russia
and the reason was is because with
German technology and Russia's resources
they would dominate the globe
so you say why did we blow up the
pipeline well we did not want Germany
signing a deal
with Russia
you said that you said that as if that
was a fact
I'm positive
why would Russia blow up their own
pipeline
I'm Not Alone by the way guys like Jeff
sacks of you know Colombia there's a ton
of guys and then the the former Defense
Minister of uke of uh Poland
when the pipeline got put out a tweet
with a picture of the blown up pipeline
said Thank You USA
he thanked the United States for blowing
up the pipeline and then he deleted the
Tweet of course the screen grabs were
hot and heavy
but so so the fact that John Brennan
said that the Russians are the lead
candidate for blowing up their own
pipeline it was a Caitlyn Johnstone
who's very off off Broadway said well we
should to win this war we just have to
wait till Russia just blows up all of
its own infrastructure
so now we blow up the pipeline it might
have been a proxy it might have been the
polls it might have been the Brits who
knows but U.S naval activities above the
pipeline the month before
um are are suspicious
but the Russian didn't blow up the
bridge they didn't blow up the Kirch
Bridge they didn't blow up the goddamn
pipeline so used the pipeline as kind of
an example what does the U.S and NATO
gain from that and what is the perceived
loss to Russia and is it literally just
keep Russia and Germany from
becoming closer
by doing that Russia Russia was rumored
to be on the cusp of saying look we're
going to deal with Germany you know
there's very few countries in the world
who've actually signed off on this
anti-russia thing Russia it Russia has
been dealing with most of the countries
in the world the whole way Well India I
think basically said right we need for
fertilizer we need the oil we need a
bunch of this stuff and and we don't
have anything against food
China and so it's really U.S and and the
people we can bully and it's a small
number
it's not Italy it's not there's a big
macron it's not exactly on board when I
um went down a a rabbit hole on this I
don't know maybe six ish months ago and
I think I even wrote uh a quick piece on
it
one of the things that just blew me out
of the water was that I think it was
Germany uh maybe some of the other
countries that normally would have been
dealing directly with Russia now we're
taking the stance we will not buy
Russian oil and so they were buying
Chinese oil which was really just
Russian going from Russia that had a
Chinese flag on it and was marked up two
acts and so when you like unpack all the
virtue signaling and the posturing and
the marketing messages like just triple
that away
is Russia one of the only countries in
the world and by you know uh kind of
Association I guess Ukraine that whole
region because of the oil because of the
natural gas because of uh their impact
on fertilizer and wheat and all this
stuff
they just have to be an interface for
global trade with many many countries
around the world regardless of what they
do
yeah well so they they Supply the world
there's only 40 of the week so they're
the swing supplier along with Saudi
Arabia
and and I guess the us if you want you
want to throw in the fracking but I
think the fracking story is starting to
Peter out
um
and so so one of our big swing suppliers
we're now operationally at war with the
other swing supplier has been acting
very ordinary to us and been talking a
lot with Putin so uh I think that it's
possible that the Arab world's about to
align with the with Asia rather than
with the United States so I I don't know
if that was happening in in the wars
because of that or if we boned it in the
war is causing that I'm not sure
um China is opaque this call I got right
before you your Zoom call some guy
called me from China and was trying to
tell me stuff about China but I couldn't
understand him
um and and so the fact that I can
understand nothing about China is what
scares me because I I've attempted to
figure out what China is up to and what
their role is there's this implicit you
know China's got various alliances with
um with um with Russia but it's such a
vague sort of implicit thing it's not
it's they're not in plain sight
and so I I don't know what China's role
is but you can bet that they're in it
deeper than we're seeing
um how does Russian end
uh one of two ways either we have a huge
conflagration
that's a big word what is that what does
that word mean
World War okay
um which may or may not involve nukes
um Ashley meersheimer says that he
thinks a nuke going off is the only way
to really stop this thing he thinks if a
nuke goes off somewhere we will then go
right to the negotiating cable and say
okay enough is enough he says but when
he was asked how do we get out of this
one in a recent podcast we said we can't
we're screwed okay that was his answer
so then let's unpack that real quick
because I think that when you say a nuke
going off that does not sound like a U.S
nuke going off that sounds like I don't
know
there's nukes all over the world you
think if one goes off or at least the
thought process would be if one goes off
regardless of the country of origin
everyone runs to the negotiating table
that's mirrorshimer's
sort of Base argument I don't think he's
saying it will work I think he's saying
is that could work because basically
that's the prisoner's dilemma that means
that everything it is absolutely the
prisoners Alum that's I've used that
analogy talking to people
um the other thing is that
um
is that um if you listen to McGregor
Douglas McGregor you listen to me or
shimmery listen these guys McGregor and
black McGregor seems to be the best
source Scott Ritter who who is a
controversial character
um they say you know if you turn on the
news you hear that Ukraine's kicking ass
and that's why we have to give more
weapons because we're so close we're on
the two yard line and we just have to
push them over the end zone and solve
this problem right
um
McGregor and and a few others are saying
that that Ukraine's getting slaughtered
that the the media is completely and
utterly wrong and here here was an
interesting scenario so when when this
war first started picking up speed
and it was a very strange thing
um the first thing that happened is we
heard the war was coming
and even in The Press Room of the White
House there were reporters saying what's
your evidence the guys who I just told
you Jake Sullivan said I just thought he
says that's not evidence what's your
evidence
and that the Press wasn't buying it and
then and then there was back and forth
like the the the uh the Brit said
something's gonna happen the Chinese
said nothing's going to happen one of
the Ministers of something or other in
Ukraine said we're not seeing evidence
they're going to attack
and so it was this chaos and at one
point some Russian put out said could
you send us the dates that we're
supposed to attack so we can plan our
vacations
right it was chaos
and I think there was um there was there
was I think at one point zelenski said
the U.S was stirring up trouble
was was stirring up uh uh uh a stretch
intention unnecessarily
so I think in the early days the only
one who had a taste for war in Ukraine
was the U.S
and I think everyone else was trying to
wiggle out of it
and and the U.S just wasn't going to let
it happen and then come the war starts
and the footage was very telling and I
kept saying to my wife this doesn't look
like a war
and she said what are you talking about
and yeah you'd show bombed out buildings
and stuff
I go but you can't see the war that's a
bombed out building I don't know what
that is and so what I did in my
interview I I actually sort of insulted
myself I say well Mr Smarty Pants or
there's no or what what what about all
these Horrors I showed eight photos of
just wiped out buildings
and then I said yeah those are horror
stories but uh but they are in order a b
c d e f g whatever
um uh Ukraine 2016 Ukraine 2022 uh uh I
think one of them was uh Baltimore one
of them was Detroit one of them was uh
one was somewhere in the Middle East and
I said I said see how easy it was to
convince you that there's a Horror Story
and I said they were just showing us
pictures of [ __ ] that you couldn't say
that's evidence there's a war and in
fact some of the footage of Mario poll
the destruction looked like it had long
since passed and it was decaying
buildings and stuff
and and the explosions were you know M80
that Dynamite size explosions in the
middle of a street hitting nothing and
then you see a car on fire you'd see
some mother squealing about how awful it
is but the really big explosions were
too far away to know what blew up
and so there was just I was looking for
these show me The Smoking Gun of this
war and I couldn't find it now what I'll
tell you is is I think the blowing up of
the pipeline in the Kirch Bridge
caused Putin to change and I think he's
inflicting horrific pain on Ukraine now
so the war did start but there was even
images of you know guys with Russian
tanks talking to civilians now
there was a great news we got a guy by a
guy named William Arkin who I discovered
relatively late
in which he wrote about the evidence
that Putin was not inflicting civilian
casualties and was not trying to destroy
the infrastructure
because he believed that he would have
to rebuild it
and so he was attempting and so so at
the very beginning of the war Ritter
says here's what Putin's going to do
before it started really
he said Putin's gonna suck the Ukrainian
military to defend the cities then he's
going to do an end run and get to the
military targets he cares about and he's
going to avoid Urban Warfare at all
costs he got slaughtered due to bad
decisions made in the Chechen War
and and the casualties caused him so
much political problems
and so he was avoiding casualties at all
costs
and and there were all these stories
coming out and then they turns out they
wouldn't hold up like the the Buca
Massacre and you find out that there's
bodies lining the straight all those
dastardly Russians then you find out
those pictures didn't start showing up
until three days after Ukraine had
control of buca
and so you got the azath guys or a bunch
of these ruthless Nazis we're willing to
kill anybody
I mean they really are like Colombian
drug lords
they're happy to litter the side of the
street with with it there was a um there
was an explosion a train station got a
lot of press 50 people died oh that's
dastardly Russians and I shot a picture
on Twitter of the missile
and I I it was intact
and I said here's a picture of the
missile let's discuss this and I just
left it at that and it turns out that I
had misread the situation and it's a
two-stage missile
when I first discovered right away
within a minute and a half the military
guys jump in and they say it's a
two-stage missile that's the first state
jettison that's not the explosive part
I go okay I stand corrected
and then um and then some guy says but
those missiles have been used by Russia
for at least five years the only guys
use those are ukrainians and they said
okay that's getting interesting and then
someone says those are unguided missiles
so if you find the first stage you find
the second stage
you can actually calculate where it was
launched from and it turns that Trace
right back to Ukrainian controlled
territory ukrainians were bombing
ukrainians which they have been doing
for a decade now there are an estimated
15 000 dead ethnic Russians in the
dambos region because they got
slaughtered by the Western ukrainians
this has been going on without anyone in
the west giving a God damn where was
your yellow and blue Ukrainian flag well
that was happening I didn't know about
it
and they were using weapons provided by
CIA NATO you name it
and so we have been fostering a civil
war in Ukraine for 10 years one of the
things that happened in the last 24
hours and I saw this and I was like oh
and I'm going to talk to Dave I can't
wait to hear his uh his response is uh
there's this guy Max Blum Blumenthal I
believe is yeah Max Blumenthal he's one
of the several dozen that I cite as
willing to talk about the other side
yeah okay so he tweeted mate and Aaron
mate he tweeted uh about 24 hours ago
and he said after months in Ukraine
training soldiers retired Colonel Andrew
Milburn of the Mozart group mercenary
firm gets Sauced on camera and Spills
the beans Ukraine is a corrupt [ __ ] up
Society run by [ __ ] up people and just
quotes there and then he says Ukrainian
soldiers
quote kill dudes who surrendered quote
and then commit quote atrocities
and it's been going on for years
Blumenthal goes on to describe uh the
Mozart group is among the largest pmcs
in Ukraine New York Times profile of
Milburn painted him as driven by The
Same pro-ukrainian Spirit that has put
yellow and blue flags flying across the
Western World yeah yeah or whatever so
that is a retired Colonel Andrew Milburn
from the Mozart group talking about how
Ukrainian soldiers were killing people
who surrendered and again I don't know
this again this is me reading what
Blumenthal is tweeting and then there's
a clip where he was on the team house
podcast uh and he's openly saying it so
unless that is not Colonel Andrew
Milburn or somehow the video is doctored
it appears that is what he's saying but
then 12 hours ago Blumenthal tweeted and
said Dan Rice a U.S army veteran
advising zelinski tells CNN that Ukraine
urgently needs cluster Munitions to
quote increase the base lethality end
quote and he complains about EU states
that signed anti-cluster bomb treaty and
Promises Ukraine's Army will clean up
unexploded Munitions and silence and
then he goes on he says zelinski's U.S
advisor and lobbyist was granted an
uncritical platform by CNN's Aaron
Burnett to appeal for Washington to
authorize illegal cluster Munitions to
Ukraine to quote win the war end quote
my takeaway from these uh two
collections of tweets
is that there is more to the story it is
not a huge amount black and white
one-way or black and white the other way
and what it always comes back to and
I've talked about this a bunch on the
podcast with various different guests is
war is a nasty nasty complex
horrible
situation where there are no winners
and I think what we're saying if you
look at some of the losers you say how's
Japan doing after World War II how did
Germany do after World War II I'm the
losers end up being the winners in some
Twisted way well in what I think we're
starting to see and again
time has a has a a very interesting way
of doing this is that more details are
coming out that are just highlighting
it's not black and white
and so for the average person who does
not have a lot of time on their hands
does not care enough to go investigate
and uh doesn't have you know
quote-unquote a dog in the fight
what ends up occurring
is they now are starting to say
themselves well what the hell is going
on because it doesn't seem like the
story initially is the full story it may
be part of the story but it's not the
full story I think that's really what
you were highlighting in the piece that
you wrote it's just like there's a lot
of [ __ ] going on here that isn't being
covered and maybe we should be asking
why
well then there's there's all these
things that show up like for example we
find out that there's 36 actually I've
seen both the number 36 and 46.
bioweapons labs in Ukraine
U.S by weapons labs in Ukraine
why do we have 46 bioweapons labs in
Ukraine and so you say oh that's just
conspiracy theory those are just old
Russian Labs that you know or
decommissioned I go well uh I read about
those in in the book demon in the
freezer many years ago and they were
terrifying because they were these
rickety-all buildings and they were
Rusty padlocks and there were a bunch of
heroin addicts who were looking to sell
germ warfare materials on the black
market to get some cash
and so when the Soviet Union fell apart
one of our biggest concerns was go in
there button those things down fast well
it turns out that we did button them
down fast they're not left over and in
2005 there's some non-luger thing that
okayed us setting up the bio weapons
labs in Ukraine and so I said oh do I
really know that there well then
Victoria [ __ ] the EU Newland
admitted they were there and that they
were struggling to get control of the
materials to get them back to the U.S
and I go what kind of materials do they
think there were well things like
modified coronaviruses to kill people
let's start there
and um
and so uh and so that there's just bad
[ __ ] in this story the story stinks to
high heaven and and what bothers me what
bothers me is the people that that the
Eric Hoffer group the Fanatics he calls
them who just sign off on this and get
suckered into it I could be dead wrong
go prove me wrong I pray I'm wrong I
want to be the good guys but right now I
am convinced we're the Bad Guys
and and if you go back through history
and you say show me where in history
there were really good guys it's very
hard to do
it's humans are brutal humans humans are
bad people I mean they're they're
there's nothing worse than a human we
cannibalize each other we we kill each
other we we and and and and if if
somehow the CIA is no longer doing [ __ ]
like this I'm reading the book right now
called poisoner in Chief what a Horror
Story what a horror story if if somehow
the CIA is no longer bad guys tell me
what year they became good guys
because I'd love to know the year that
someone said okay let's stop being bad
because the [ __ ] they were doing in the
50s and the 60s was horrific Dr Mengele
level horrific
and so the question is what makes you
think the U.S are good guys
I see no evidence we are we are good
domestically so far I would say that's
slipping very quickly
the fact that there's still guys who
have not stood trial and are in solitary
confinement after January 6 is evidence
that we have real authoritarian blood
coursing through our veins that's a
Horror Story
is the U.S the best country in the world
to live in or do you think that there's
other gases yes so it's like even with
the the black eyes and and the bad stuff
and all the things you're hiring well
they're not hurting for the most part
they're not hurting their own people
they're trying not to again if you're
afraid what the if you read the the real
Anthony how should you read you know
poison in Chief we are hurting some of
our own people
um pretty gruesomely but um but for the
most part we have a great existence so I
don't want to tear down the system
because our system is the best system I
mean there's probably countries like you
know who knows maybe living in Sweden is
much better you know but but but but
considering all the burden all the
baggage we carry
we're still okay but we're great risk of
not being okay
it's I read a number of books going back
all the way Tony blankly's book before
he died the West last chance I think it
was uh there's a lot of guys Jonah
Goldberg there's a lot of guys who think
that we're on the precipice and that the
American experiment which has been a
brilliant experiment
is at risk of being thrown away because
we've forgotten
what got us here now there's a great
story of chesterton's fence that I used
that one last time and Brett Weinstein
drew it to my attention
um in his book
um guy's about to tear down a fence
and and his friend says well do you know
why they put the fence up in the first
place the guy said no he said well you
better answer that question before he
tear it down mm-hmm
and it's it's a great sort of metaphor
it's a great Maxim where is is before
you
before you get rid of some long-standing
tradition like Catholicism I'm an
atheist sort of
um make sure you understand what it was
and wasn't doing for society and I don't
even know what to call myself now
because I'm not religious but I I think
we're attempting to push religion to the
back burner and I think religion has
been a glue
that I personally grotesquely
underestimated its importance and
there's called the the Lindy effect I
think it's called I think it may be the
same Talib pushes this I don't know but
the longer something is in existence
longer it'll last
that's right and and and Weinstein's
take on this I had a long chat with Eric
Weinstein the other day it was quite
enlightening he's talking about brains
the size of cantaloupes
um
the longer something's been around the
more likely is that it's serving an
important purpose whether it's a
physical thing like your appendix or
whether it's um which they're now
figuring out what it does
it's not just hanging off the end of
your intestines doing nothing
um to something social like like
Catholicism or religion or whatever
um don't underestimate the importance of
its existence because it's been around
for thousands of years people who are
anti-government I go you know we've been
choosing government over non-government
for 5 000 years
what makes you think the choice of
non-government is the best choice
so to be a Libertarian is one thing to
be an ex a maximalist Libertarian is
stupid
I had a professor in college uh who I
forget what exactly the class was but
it's philosophy or or sociology
something like that and uh he made the
argument one day in class pissed a lot
of people off a lot of people off which
uh you know kudos to him for even being
willing to uh to have the conversation
but he basically made the argument that
uh
you can argue that everything about
religion is wrong and accurate and uh
it's basically fiction and still argue
that it's important for people to
believe because it holds together that
social Fabric and it's actually the
thing that keeps people psychologically
in the game and they believe that uh you
know it is better it they believe that
there is something uh more positive in
the world they believe that there is
something you know when they die like
and you kind of walk through the whole
argument and again whether you uh
wherever you fall I made that argument
in print I made that argument in print I
I opened the discussion of pro-religion
I think I was inspired by Charles Murray
actually okay who's also a polarizing
figure
um I I said look I'm a pro-choice
atheist and I refer to myself as a pagan
with a noisy sword
but I'm now going to write in defense of
religion and I wrote about four or five
pages defending the gluing effect that
religion has had and that I am
benefiting from the judeo-christian
ethic
that I personally am not actively
involved in but I'm benefiting from it
it's sort of like hammering Silicon
Valley for being a bunch of douchebags
but forgetting that by the way your
[ __ ] phone came from there well
you're tweeting it on your iPhone
didn't assume didn't come from Peoria
Illinois right
uh the last thing I want to talk about
is uh FTX you have a whole section in uh
in your end of year Roundup and your
main point is just the FTX story is not
a crypto story it's a geopolitical story
unpack a little bit uh in terms of why
is this on your radar and why do you
think it's so much bigger than maybe
people are giving credit for
well so as soon as the story broke which
I you know me I I know the only thing I
know about crypto is what I learned from
doing podcasts with you and Marty batt
and and and various devout hodlers
who've been attempting to who knock on
my door with the Bible underneath their
arm trying to convert me
um by the way you mentioned earlier
index uh the index arise in the 90s
right and one of the things uh people
have yet to connect but I think is
important is uh passive indexing is very
similar to uh huddling it is uh right
they continued accused acquisition of an
asset that you believe will be worth
more in the future than it is today and
and so
my detraction of crypto
a Bitcoin forget crypto there's what 20
000 cryptos 19
990 something of them will have to die
you know that I know that right you're
not going to have 20 000 cryptos running
around this is like all the banknotes in
the United States from all the different
banks across the country back in the mid
19th century they all died
um
that's not to say that Bitcoin dies or
it's also not to say that you know which
one will survive but I do I during the
the FDX collapse I did learn something
about the difference between how Bitcoin
works and and I don't need to understand
it
uh I I I I do probably to become a
huddler
uh you guys call them hodlers I think
hodler makes more sense but um that's
just me
um
um the reason that I doubt the hodlers
is because I do believe to the depth of
my soul that you guys either are going
to be absorbed like the tea party wing
of the Republican Party becoming
Republicans again or or you're gonna
have to do a battle of the bastards and
you're gonna have to survive I I believe
that at some point you'll be absorbed by
the Banks or you will be and and
therefore it'll become pretty generic
and it won't be what people right now
are enjoying or they're going to destroy
you and I believe they have mechanisms
to destroy you despite despite the total
autonomy that you can achieve by holding
your own keys and things like that
because I think they can make it so
unpleasant
for anyone who tries to use crypto
that um that that if they decide that
crypto's not in their interest now if
they decide it's in their interest then
it's a different path but I'm not sure
it's a win still which because I think
that which path do you think is likely
I'm torn I don't know
every time I've talked to you you you
are uh you're one of the only people I
know who I think you're standing at the
fork in the road and you can clearly
identify the two pounds you're like Tom
Hanks in the movie Castaway standing in
the fork at the road at the end of the
movie you you won't think
no and I'm waiting for an event you know
I had a long I had lunch with Larry
Lepard who's a big Bitcoin enthusiastic
and I really respect Larry hi Larry and
um
and I could be converted but I don't
know it people say what price would
convert you and the answer is not about
a price
there's not some crypto has no inherent
value that that I can price it in even
gold has such a thing so gold you know
the favorite thing gold is it's always
been able to buy a fancy suit
the problem with that statement is that
what's a fancy suit in ancient Rome it's
a rag with a it's a toga right so I that
doesn't help me what gold also has
bought since the dawn of time is it is a
month's worth of manual labor and that
hasn't changed at all
and that's the better metric so gold
does have a valuation metric that you
can stick to
um
but that's not to say it won't pick one
up because it is the becomes the
currency of the saying and the currency
of the realm and the currency of
whatever so so I don't think it has to
be tangible to be the the go-to currency
uh it has changed over the years too by
the way at first it was going to be used
to buy pizza and you go ah not really
it's it's really more of an asset so
there's been a drift in this story
I am waiting for some moment
where it just clicks in my skull it says
it's real they're gonna win
time to buy
and and I'm just I'm waiting it's going
to be it's like porn I know when I see
it you know every night maybe but yeah
and um
and so so that's my view on crypto
um the FTX story as soon as it broke
obviously I paid some attention because
it was exciting and you had that 24 7
um a 24 7 Twitter spaces where kim.com
was fighting with some other huddlers
they were trying to keep track of what
was going on
um in the FTX collapse which was great
and then all of a sudden out of the blue
they have as a guest Hunter Biden I go
wow
what the hell is that all about right so
I had spotted the connection the
connection of of
um the FTX token was it ftt or something
I think it's called
um and Ukraine very quickly
and I recognize the geopolitical
component of the FDX collapse very
quickly so within a day I think and and
so I put out a tweet
it was a Hail Mary tweet that said
before this story is over there's going
to be there's going to be hodlers
washing up on beaches around the world
and that turned out to be true so there
have been some prominent humblers who
have found themselves literally dead on
beaches around the world and and one of
them was said that he was about to be
framed and the Messiah was going to get
him and then boom ends up dead and so
there's been some and I don't know how
many because I I don't know how to keep
track of them and stuff but there was
enough to say oh that was a good tweet
um
so it appears to me as though FTX was
never meant to be a legitimate operation
it wasn't like they started it they had
a good heart and they knew what they
were doing and and and then they got
behind some eight ball right and that
can happen right I think some of the
stable coins they started out that way
but I you could spot a problem with
stable coins as soon as they start
giving away stable coins up and they
kind of go well now you're underfunded
he just gave away the the reserve
of your stable coin and then I heard
that they were holding you know crypto
as assets for the stable Clinic oh okay
this is just nuts so I think the stable
coins I think there can be a bunch of
problems going forward even but they've
they've been sort of have started to get
dealt with
I've not been able to understand what
that will mean to bitcoin holders I
don't know and I asked Marty and I asked
guys like you and I get kind of a
guarded optimism but I'm not sure it's
not just a self-preservation optimism
but I it seems to me if the stable
clients really get the crap kicked out
of them if tether goes I I think there's
going to be a period of Chaos
and that might be the battle of the
bastards that might be the moment where
I go okay that that's kind of a bottom
and they're surviving and they didn't
need tether and they didn't right but um
so
um quickly I picked up the connection of
FTX to Ukraine which is really what got
me paying close attention and then I
started finding videos of guys who were
you know off off Broadway describing the
thing these are not the stories coming
out of Glenn Greenwald stuff these are
guys standing in front of their camera
describing what was happening and I
started to pick up the you know gay
bankman freed and Laura bankman freed I
started to pick up the different players
I go holy [ __ ] this is crooked as [ __ ]
and to make a long story short it looks
to me like fgx was never intended to be
anything but a crime syndicate
and that it was intended to launder
money
and the losses we hear quoted 10 billion
is that close uh that was the total
number of assets I believe on the
platform I don't know if they've come to
a conclusion as to how much is lost but
let's say up to 10 billion I guess is
okay
so
I think the best model
is that it was used as a platform to
launder money
and so what we we know the losses what
we don't know is the flow rate through
the FTX system
and so for example
um the great model is that Biden gives
Ukraine money
Ukraine somehow with the aid of of FTX
was laundering money back to the DNC
into various packs that had funny
friendly fuzzy names about fighting
pandemics and and fighting all sorts of
things but it was just basically shoving
money back into the DNC
which then caused Biden to give more
money to Ukraine again
so it really appeared to be a round trip
of of taxpayer money somehow using FTX
to get to Ukraine Ukraine's National
Bank was involved and then it was ending
back in the DNC and and pretty recently
uh the press secretary what's her name
do you know her name
I can never remember it Pierre or
something Karen Pierre or something JP I
think is the initials right yeah
um she was asked are you going to give
the money back to help make people whole
who got who lost their life savings and
she applied the fifth I'm going oh so
you are a skanky [ __ ] I got it
um and so no they're not going to give
the money back and so life savings ended
up in the DNC so if you I'm not a jury
and you take an AK-47 and you go into
the dnc's office to wipe them out I'm
hanging the jury
I'm hanging it I'm not convicting that
bastard that they're gonna have to do a
new trial because I'm not letting them I
don't care if if the DNC stole my life
savings I'd be looking to get even
I don't know how I would dedicate my
ample brain to find a way to make the
DLC pay for that and so I think that
that one of my favorite parts of the
write-up I did is I so so then the
bizarre part is you got Sam bankman
fraud
um
out in the on the streets and in the
digital world doing interviews
and doing and and as a guest on that on
that that Twitter spaces
spilling his guts I'm going
who are your lawyers who's telling you
to do this
and and and he was doing this this this
I'm just I'm just a kid who didn't get
it and I didn't really understand what
was happening and I didn't know where
co-mingling funds and blah blah blah so
boy Genius turns book turns out to be
you know so I referred to it as a uh as
an episode of Leave it to Beaver where
the beef got himself into trouble again
and in the end I said look you know
without Lassie Timmy would have a life
expectancy of About a Week who's
watching out for you
and uh I think
um I think he could be now called I've
referred to him as as Sam bankman
Epstein
I think he can have a life expectancy of
a nap pretty soon
um and I think there's I think it's a
much much bigger Scandal that they're
trying to put away I think it's kind of
an Epstein level Scandal they're trying
to put away
and I don't have the details but it just
smells smells the holy hell of of this
and uh and the fact that the Republicans
are not beating up the Democrats on this
tells me that it's crooked I know that
um
that I know that for example Mitch
McConnell
do you want cause me to switch parties
Mitch will do it
um Mitch McConnell who is truly a the
most despicable of Republicans in my
opinion and and it's not a short list of
Despicable Republicans
um
completely refused to fund anything in
Arizona while Carrie lakes in a brawl
with with what's her face Hobbs
uh what's there Katie Hopps
now speaking of you know riding Empire
you know Katie Hobbs was in this close
race with with Kerry Lake
and who was in charge of overseeing the
election Katie Hobbs she oversaw her own
election
hey guys I'm back Dave's saying
something that YouTube won't allow now
let's get back to the episode with Dave
column
but all the guys who attach themselves
to Maga lost
what what a you know maybe it's
tactically bad
or maybe it was way of saying if you
touch the Maga story
we're going to destroy you both parties
neither party wants Maga
Republicans don't want him either just
like they didn't want the Tea Partiers
so
um so I think that's the FDX story I
think FTX is a money laundering scheme
that's much darker more Sinister than
just some idiots from MIT
who are having orgies I said by the way
you know it sounds awfully pizzagated to
me
um
which I'm actually a believer in
um so that's that's my FTX sorry what's
wrong with this story tell me tell me
what the counter argument is I don't
know if there is anything wrong or
counter argument or even if we have all
the details to uh
the detail put together a uh a counter
I'm in this weird place right where
um I've talked to some of the people who
are involved in this uh you know on the
podcast or or uh conferences over the
years did I see you at CNBC or fox or
something what did I see you at oh I
went on CNBC for a three-minute segment
that turned into a 20-minute horn
locking with uh our boy Scott partner
yeah oh wapter yeah yeah I saw that we
looked unpleasant to me we had uh well
look it's uh
actually I never I haven't talked about
this yet so 20 minutes on national
television with someone who is not there
to be your friend uh in the interview
because that's his job right I don't
think he was doing anything outside of
you know he's trying to ask tough
questions or whatever
people forget like that's not fun how do
you think I'd respond under those
conditions would I just lose my [ __ ] and
rip them a new one with everything I got
or what in case you can't do that I am
you really had to keep your [ __ ]
together which you did yeah yeah and you
know uh I think Scott would say this as
well as I I just probably have more
command of uh the Technologies in the
market like on in the business right
like that is what I do on a day-to-day
basis this is one of many things that he
has to pay attention to and so uh from
that standpoint you know I probably have
an advantage but also I'm on his Turf
and I don't know what the questions are
so a little balancing there
um I always say that it's not about how
you act on the uh uh the current
situation it's always can you get your
point across and uh be invited back
right the the invitation
yeah maybe if maybe if if there's
another turn in the the crypto plot you
might yeah yeah the well in 2018 look I
I uh I used to go on all the time and uh
Kevin O'Leary who now is somehow you
know one of the one of the players in
the whole FTX thing and has been out
there kind of talking through various
parts of it uh there's this you know
classic video he literally says to me
and how much of your money's in this and
I tell him and he goes I forbid this and
he's yelling and screaming at me and
he's got the finger point the whole
thing and you got to remember some of
it's entertainment right obviously
that's why people watch and and I always
cite if you remember Bill Ackman and uh
Carl Icahn calling in to CNBC live
together yelling and screaming at each
other and Carl's saying Billy came to
see me and I told Billy he was an idiot
you can hear that I won that as I recall
right icon kicked his ass and then snuck
out the back door with his money yeah
well and you the part I love about it is
as they're doing that uh live you know
entertaining debate between billionaires
on National Television you hear the
traders in the background and each time
one of them scores kind of verbal points
you hear them kind of yeah
yeah yeah I remember that it was great
right it was great it was like Kelly did
the Tea Party rant right yeah there's a
couple of these throughout the years
where I think you can point to and say
look this is obviously has an
entertaining uh component to it outside
of what is you know somewhat of a dry
topic for for most Americans uh and
people around the world now when it
comes to the FTX stuff what what is
um a part of where maybe I'm perplexed
is is very obvious that there was public
coverage of one side of the political
Spectrum receiving donations from uh FTX
Sam however you want to kind of
characterize the players and
organization but then it's come out that
actually there was money that was being
donated to both parties right that's
right at least uh at least a half a
dozen to a dozen Republicans got money
yeah and so you get that and then I saw
um there was a story that was written I
think uh Beto in Texas he had received
like a million bucks or something and
then like the day before the election he
gave it back but it was before uh the
blow up and just like there's a lot of
these details and stuff that you're just
kind of like I now want more information
before I come to to hey here is my Like
official uh opinion on it because it
just feels like every day we get more
information and you're just like what is
going on right I found myself more than
any story over the last two years asking
myself what is going on here uh with
this very much so very much and but it
really looks dirty as [ __ ] well what I
don't know is how much of it is because
I'm in this industry you know uh our
media business had a uh one of the
advertisers was ftxus regulated us-based
exchange right the whole nine yards uh
there's been Fallout from this other
companies that I would investor in or an
uh uh advertised uh they have been
affected and so some of it is definitely
just like if you're in an industry and
something like this happens naturally
you're going to hear a lot about it
you're gonna uh it's gonna constantly
come up in conversation but then I
talked to friends that are completely
outside of uh kind of the the Bitcoin or
crypto industry and even they're talking
about it like okay right this is not
just a uh a crypto thing this is
definitely kind of escaped that into a
much bigger story well so so here's the
question I have for you is it is it
going to be used
to influence the crypto World by the
authorities and I don't know what
influence means yeah so what's
fascinating about this
um and again plexing at the same time
right it's fascinating and perplexing is
that this was not one of the exchanges
that was at least publicly stating we
don't want to be regulated it wasn't an
anarchist you know saying take down the
US government it wasn't somebody who was
um openly trying to avoid going and
talking to Regulators or politicians or
whatever it was quite the opposite
and so
um was it intentional maybe was it uh
ignorance and stupidity maybe was it a
combination of all the above probably
right you know whatever
the ignorance is stupidity by the way
this this is this is I'm reminded of
January 6 on this I I think
for example the FBI is informants
the informants I think
believe that because they're tied to the
FBI they're safe they don't realize that
they can be written out of the plot any
day
and so for example if you are a rabble
if you're an FBI sponsored gravel Rouser
at January 6.
that no way guaranteed you would be
arrested and thrown in jail for five
years
um
and so
um
the Absurd part of the story to me is is
that um
that not only did um
SPF
not understand
how shark infested these Waters were
but he his parents apparently didn't
either
and so his parents
who really do look like they must have
somehow been involved because for one
thing they bought real estate off FTX
money and stuff like that
um they let their son walk into a snake
pit
and so if my models at all remotely
correct and that is the whole thing
has been to process money
which I can't see evidence against that
um
then then his parents let him play in a
very dangerous place
and and
by the way hey guys I'm back Dave's
saying something that YouTube won't
allow now let's get back to the episode
with Dave column
YouTube's algorithm appreciates it yeah
right they probably don't pick that
subtlety up
um all right I got so I got one last
question for you on uh on FTX and then
we'll wrap up which is what do you think
happens what what is the the end result
when we're recording this
um Sam uh was arrested in the Bahamas
he's now been extradited back to the
United States uh he was released on a uh
Bond
um and uh is I think living at his
parents house at the moment there are
two other uh players
um I think Gary Wong is uh name one and
then Caroline they have both pleaded
guilty and are cooperating with
investigators
um how does this play out in you know
two three jail times
what do you think happens I guess to
them maybe even to uh uh the larger
bankruptcy case like how do you well it
depends it depends on how deeply they
understood the game they were playing
and so
um
a number of paths can be followed if
they're
knowledgeable and highly dangerous they
could go the Epstein route if if they
were suckers if they were the patsies
and they were enjoying their little fun
they could end up in prison
um as long as they can't think any
important people
um
and and
I could imagine a scenario that by the
time it's done after the whole fears
died down that nothing really
consequential happened let me put it
this way
if he's a legitimate hudler of any kind
if he doesn't have a bunch of money
socked away in the blockchain
he's out of his court
right so he is not broke
there's there's no way that he had
billions
and didn't put some [ __ ] basically into
a Swiss bank account equivalent on the
blockchain
is that right
I have no clue
but it would be put it this way he if he
didn't he sure wondered why now
of course the um do you know this so
that would be down right stupid do you
know the story of uh uh Dan Bilzerian
you know who that is
Dan I know Alex builds Aaron Dan's the
um the actor uh yeah well actor I think
he was in a movie Yes
um he also is uh very popular so Alex is
his nephew I think or or cousin okay I
know Alex he's a physicist he's a sort
of a Silicon Valley type physicist so I
I
um we'll get the details wrong so I
won't even try but uh long story short
is that Dan's father was a corporate
Raider back in like the 80s uh I believe
70s 80s whenever it was and um at some
point uh front door got kicked in by uh
Federal prosecutors law enforcement Etc
uh I believe he did uh jail time and
um
then his son pops up there's a bunch of
money
and uh lives a very lapis lifestyle son
was a professional player
right uh or at least was playing poker
and uh and talks about that's where uh
which is a money laundering mechanism
right there yeah so again I I don't know
but I think that uh your point about
um just very you know the the this story
has repeated over and over and I've
talked to a number of people who've been
around for a long time and they're like
look there's you know four or five
details in every one of these stories
that all seem to kind of overlap uh and
that's not to say that these people know
each other or anything like that it's
just like these usually un unravel in a
very specific way
um and it seems like so far this one is
is following that trend
well so
I got a figure that Sam is in trouble
I just I I he's he got too visible
and and whether they say look you're
gonna have to do 10 years in Club Fed
and your life will not be so bad
they'll be you know you can wait left
and you can swim and things like that
but um it could be that
um if I'm wrong about how deeply
embedded FTX from the political system
was then then he'll just get hammered
you know ill but but I I don't think I'm
wrong on that because I think there's
way too much evidence pointing to the
fact that he was money was going to
powerful they were even funding the
Lincoln project they were funding uh
they funded the they funded the um the
um
the the clinical study that showed
Ivermectin doesn't work
I mean they were up to their ass and
everything bad
and so so I really think that I I don't
know if Sam knew
uh the game he was in
I don't feel sorry for him he had to
have known he was breaking laws and
doing bad things but I think when you're
hanging out with the cool kids
you somehow think that you're also one
of the cool kids
um here's a question I like to ask
people rhetorically we know how much
child trafficking is a problem right
when was the last time someone got
arrested for receiving a child
right these kids can't come cheap
they're not selling these kids in
trailer parks
where are these kids going
when was the last time someone got got
convicted
of receiving
a child
I can't name them the the one I come
with I think Denny hastert got himself
in a little bit of trouble but that
could have also been who what who did he
piss off
but that was years ago so if child
trafficking is rampant like we hear and
sometimes you see some story where they
say you know 30 kids out of the back of
you all right
if they hadn't intercepted that U-Haul
there'd be 30
wretched
deserving to die people receiving those
kids
where are they
ever wondered about that
you said that was rhetorical question so
I'll leave it at that but uh I think
that
well let me put it this way I don't own
any of them so you know I'm saying I
think that uh
asking questions is a good thing
I think that more people should ask
questions
maybe not uh not just by so back to the
just to finish the Ukraine story I could
have a lot of stuff wrong
but if if you think I do dig into it
right that is
full credit for which is uh anyone who's
watching this or listening to this uh if
you disagree with something Dave said go
on Twitter email them the whole thing he
will uh he will read it he will engage
uh and if you've shown that he's wrong
he'll change his mind which uh which I
appreciate as well
um you know very few people will
actually go and message you or uh or do
the research but uh but I think that you
would encourage them to do that
I I would I'd love to think I'm wrong
about the dark stuff
but the the problem is that
every time I go down a rabbit hole I
find
I don't find rabbits I find stuff
and so you know
I want someone to tell me what the great
reset is
it's real Klaus Schwab is real they make
absurdly bizarre statements
about what the world should be
they are heavily funded they are
globalists
they say things that no one would
believe they'd say because you go this
is one of the most recent catchphrases
was there's no reason why life has to be
fulfilling
what what person says that
right this was on their website
so what is their purpose are these a
bunch of you Genesis are they going to
try to bring the population down under a
billion is that their goal because
there's no other model
there's no other model it's either
global domination or you know Global
destruction
you know maybe it's destruction of the
United States had your mom right
but it's not simple
and I've I've called out so many people
and say please explain to me what the
gray reset is
because they they garishly speak about
it and I've read a lot of books on
totalitarianism I've read a lot of books
on propaganda
and one of the two common things I use
is one is fear okay covet
the second is demoralization and that's
where I put the garishness part
so if they can garishly say we're coming
through the front door and you're not
going to be able to deal with it and
we're going to squash the truckers we
don't care how bad we look
that's demoralizing
hey guys
Dave's saying something that YouTube
won't allow now let's get back to the
episode with Dave column
[Music]
and then the question is
um
why are they still pushing it
it's it's almost like a
like when we diss the Russians we don't
care what you think
we're going to do it did I you can
you're welcome by the way you have my
authorization to delete statements I
won't give you I won't give you Guff
to keep this thing on YouTube
I I I I won't hold it against you if I
if I watch the game game films and say
oh he took that part out I'm okay with
it
because that's the world we live in
and it's a sick world
and but it's also a world that every
other country and every other period in
history has experienced
and somehow in the United States for
various periods we felt that we were
we were the good guys
and I think we have a great existence
here
but I don't think we're the good guys
I don't think we're the worst guys
we've got a lot a lot to to shoulder I
mean the United States is the policeman
of the world which I've now been
convinced that I at least understand why
we are the policemen of the world I used
to have this Monroe Doctrine View
but if U.S ever stopped projecting
military power
globalization would cease that day
be gone that day
because the thing that allows ships to
travel 12 000 miles to deliver goods and
services
is that there's people going
you know if we in any way cause that to
stop
United States military is going to come
and kill us
and that's what is allowed globalization
to get to where it is today
it's the projection of U.S force we're
the only truly Blue Water Navy in the
world
and uh and so I understand it but I
think we're abusing it I think we're
abusing that power it's we should walk
softly and carry a big stick we somehow
stomp around and smack people with it
it's different now
where can we send people if they want to
reach out to you
well they can always find my email if
they can't they're too stupid I really
if the barrier is knowing that I'm a
Cornell professor in the chemistry
Department if that's not enough to get
my email
then I don't want to talk to you
otherwise people send me emails people
call me I talk to people I get cold
calls that's okay
um
my actual contact point with the world
is is Twitter
David B column I have you get a bunch of
these um mirroring accounts that look
like you that aren't you you get those
tons
yeah what are they bought
but what are this what's the purpose
uh from what I've seen friends of send
me screenshots they try to scam them I
got them on telegram on Instagram on
Twitter or whatever and they're
basically strike up a conversation uh as
if they're I've got this crypto for you
actually one of my friends followed up
on one and they said they were trying to
sell them some X coin a [ __ ] coin right
yeah or the uh the classic uh send me
one I'll send you two
yeah I know my son someone tried to scam
him I said okay here's what's coming
next just so you know called it to a t
the guy sent him a check for too much
money he said look just cash it send me
a check back for the difference I said
no no no no no no no don't do that
my wife got hit by a scammer let me tell
you ever so quick story
I get a cough my wife saying you know
someone hacked our computer our router
and they're emptying my our bank account
says I'm talking you gotta get home
right away
and I go no get off the phone what do
you she's on the phone with a guy from
Apple I go no you're not
and I couldn't get her to hang up on the
guy so first I reached out to the banks
and I make sure and there's no activity
there so I said uh somehow put a flag on
the account so I went to all the
accounts put a flag
and then I get I call the neighbor
because I'm I'm while I'm doing this I
said get Candice off the phone run next
door get off the phone she's being
scammed I get home
she's still on the phone she's with a
guy that she thinks is from Apple
and i i s I said Candace and I said give
me the phone
I said and I talked to the guy and I
said here's the deal if you're
legitimate you'll understand why I have
to ask my wife a couple of questions
and I went and asked I said did they
send you a number to call she said yes
she's and then they they they they said
they they helped her they helped her
lock down her LL Bean charge card they
go oh that's a problem
um and uh and and then she says no but
and I looked at the screen they had
control of her screen I said but they
only have control of your screen
and the guy was talking through and says
okay we're going to lock this down we're
going to do this and guys how he sounds
real nice I said Okay
um
you're a scam artist but I'm going to
give you one shot at convincing me
you're not
and he says well I'm just trying to help
your wife with a real serious problem
here and I go that's not a good answer
I said you're a scammer she says well
you're insulting me and I go now I know
you're a scam artist because a real I.T
guy would completely and utterly
sympathize with me
and so we're done so I hung up
and then about 30 minutes later they
called my wife back thinking I might
might have gone back to work
wow
and I said look
um dude
don't call us back and if if I and I
know this may sound like a hollow threat
but um but if you do I'm gonna come and
find you
I said I said I have high ranking Tech
friends I will find you
so don't call us back
and uh my wife was so violated by it
and and uh
they scanned Cornell they they sent they
sent an email looked like it came from
HR and it said login and do something
simple something trivial and you try to
log in and you didn't get in so most
people said oh Cornell website [ __ ] up
they took your login attempt went to the
HR window changed direct deposits
of people's paychecks
this is Banks in Malaysia or something
and so you didn't find out you've been
scammed until your paycheck didn't show
up
a lot of people don't notice their
paycheck doesn't show for quite a while
because they're not balancing their
books and stuff and so that's when
Cornell went to the double double level
login they said okay time to get serious
they ended up reimbursing about six
faculty wow for uh for having lost a
paycheck
so it's getting to be tougher I know
you're more techy than me so I just it's
getting to be a tough world to negotiate
everyone's trying to scam everyone's
lying their lips are moving their lion
you reduce 50 of the attempts just don't
answer the phone and don't respond to
text messages
I tell my wife said you never ever call
back a number or reach back to a number
they give you
but then Todd Harrison you know Todd
Harrison he's from former Morgan Stanley
did a he did a I got an email from him
and said I'd like you to take a look at
this
and I'm going oh this is [ __ ]
and so I went into my email address book
and I independently sent Todd an email
and said I just got something that they
want me you said you want me to look at
because he could have
and his response was yeah something I
thought you'd be interested in and I I
clicked on it and it didn't do anything
because I was on a Mac and it was a few
years back I go over to Twitter and this
time he says I'm not emailing anybody
and what had happened is someone got a
hold of his email box sent out all these
messages
and then every incoming message to his
email box got sent to trash and deleted
so they had complete control wow
and uh I'm going this is this is a tough
world this is going to be tough to
negotiate the older I get the Dumber I
get
and uh they're gonna dupe me and I you
know they empty my 401k or something my
retirement account I'm not going to be
happy
Sam bagman freed
Dave I always enjoyed talking to you if
anyone has not read your year in review
I highly suggest they go print it out
sit down get a little hot chocolate
Maybe
sit there for 16 hours and read the
whole thing but this one's smaller I
know I've got a third part I haven't
written but I'm not sure I'm going to
write it it's on covet I'm not sure
people want to hear about covet I I
found it fantastic so thank you so much
for taking the time to write these every
single year and thank you for uh for
always coming on and uh and talking
through things I I always enjoyed and I
think people do as well so thank you
well our last one did really well and
click count and uh and I thought it went
really well so I'm hoping this one
stands up to that standard and I always
enjoy the chat even if you forgot to
record it
happened I've had people forget to
record of course
I've never done that but you know Dave
Colin ladies and gentlemen thank you so
much
thank you